thank you to the members of the public
who've also joined us today
um mayor first of all remind us some of
the domestic arrangements that we just
need to run through this morning
please can you ensure that my friends
are muted when you're not speaking
i ask that if you are not speaking you
turn your camera off as well which we've
already done
please try not to interrupt each other
and if you could just put your hand
up that will attract my attention
members are reminded not to use the
messaging or
chat function during the meeting members
are reminded that they should not have
alternative communication lines open in
other words
skype chats and that if you are
contacted by a third party during the
meeting
you should bring it to the attention of
our legal advisors please
can i remind you that you are attending
the meeting to speak if you are
attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave the meeting
additionally we will be using the hands
up function so please use this if you
wish
to speak or indicate to me you wish to
speak
if you you do have any problems with
poor connection issues
in the first instance try turning off
your camera if you are speaking at the
time
if that does not work please turn off
all ink
coming video that does sometimes help
and these options can be found under the
three
dots located in the middle of the
toolbar
on your screen on the information bar
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live on the
internet
and will be capable of repeated viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting
you will be deemed by mid-suffolk
district council to consent it to have
been recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
uh today joining us we have uh in terms
of from mid software district council we
have ian de prez who is our legal
adviser
good morning ian good morning sherman
i'm here yet thank you
robert carmichael who's the governance
officer
robert good morning
if you just turn your camera on i just
think it's beneficial for everyone just
to see who everyone is just so we all
know
thanks very much john paytman g who's
the area planning manager
john good morning good morning
good morning can't give you a video i'm
afraid i'm okay
jamie edwards who's going to be one of
the case officers
and we will hide good morning jamie and
we'll have the ward members who will
come on uh during the application
so just to remind everyone that at
mid-south district council the ward
members may
speak on applications in their ward but
may not vote
can i now move on to the agenda
first item on the agenda is apologies
for absence and substitutions
who ask the governance officer just to
roll call members
present please thank you chair
uh so if i if you could please respond
with president or good morning
councillor john field
good morning council lavinia hattingham
present councillor hicks yep
present councillor sarah mansell
that hasn't worked hello yes present
morning
john matheson good morning councillor
richard mayer
president council david muller
president and councillor andrew stringer
who is substituting for councillor ebern
today
lovely thank you very much um agenda
item number two is to receive any
declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest
by members if anyone does have any
peculiar non-procurement interest
declare can you please use the hand up
func the hands up function
are there any nope okay
that's non-declared thank you very much
uh agenda item number three is
decorations of lobbying
uh if anyone has any declarations of
lobbying again can you
use the hand up function please
nope nonetheless declare thank you very
much agenda yes
yes yes we've put our hands up yeah
that's very strange because i'm not
seeing any at all on my screen
i've certainly got mine up as well i saw
yeah i haven't got any hands up on my
screen robert so you're going to have to
manage that because for some reason
none have come up okay yeah i'll make a
suggestion
i think you're down as a attendee not
presenter i don't know if that stops you
seeing things
i i'm that's possible hold on
do you have the list open at the side
chair yeah i do
you might need to scroll down um because
it might just be that they're on the
top part shows presenters and the
attendees
should have like under counsel having
them does it show anything there
no nothing oh okay well i'll draw if
chair if
you're happy to i'll draw your attention
to it yeah okay we'll just have to i'm
not sure why it normally does come up on
the right hand box
you know when a hand comes up you can
follow it but there's none showing okay
so
uh robert can you just run through
declarations of interest please run
through the members
yeah so councillor sarah mansell
uh yeah i i've been lobbied on both
applications uh that we were
seeing this morning is that all you need
to know yeah
thank you who's councillor matheson
i've also been lobbied on both
applications
councillor muller yes i too have been
lobbied on both applications
council of mayor
yes i've been lobbied on both
applications
council had i i i suspect all of us have
been
except for possibly councillor stringer
because he was a substitution
is that fair council stringer have you
had any lobbying
i'm not aware of any lobbying so it's
all of us apart from council stringer
because we've
he's substituting okay
thank you for that um okay any
decorations of personal site visits by
members
robert r anyone got any hands up please
i have i did a site visit to um hoxton
yesterday it's lavinia haddington
okay thank you very much anyone else
nope
okay uh thank you for that next up is uh
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting that was held on the 24th of
june
um now are there any points regarding
accuracy of the minutes
if there are i'm happy just to come in
would you like anyone like to come in
councillor field
uh just a question on page nine
uh the um section
119 0.11 it talks about
ensuring ring fencing of money secured
in section 106
are used for the brantford air area
which i'll recall
but it has a brackets that says money
includes spartan on the west
ipswich fringe which i don't recall as
part of our discussion uh
what would do some evidence okay what
we'll do is we'll just go back and
listen to the tape and just double check
that i think that's the easiest way
we're never going to resolve that now
so can i leave that with you just to
play that back apart from that item was
there anything else
okay so could i have a proposer
and a seconder for these on the
understanding that item 11811 will just
play back the tape and confirm exactly
what was said
i'll propose it and who is that please
councilman
thank you very much and who would like
to second i'm having a second vineyard
handing him
thank you very much and all those in
favor is that agreed
anyone disagree nope thank you sorry we
have to do a roll call vote
okay for that so okay
if you could please uh respond with for
against
or abstain um
so councillor john field floor
council lavina hattingham councilor
matthew hicks
four councillor sarah mansell
four councillor john matheson four
councillor richard mayer four caster
david muller
four
abstain i wasn't there thank you chair
that's carried
lovely thank you very much everyone uh
the minutes have been confirmed and
they'll now be signed at the obviously
normally i'd sign them during the
meeting but we don't have that facility
when we're operating
operating virtually so they'll be signed
at the next practical
opportunity okay next up is agenda item
number six to receive any notifications
of petitions in accordance with the
council's petitions
scheme uh robert can you come in
none receive chair i'm received okay
thank you very much
uh agenda item number
seven is a scheduler planning
applications
before we begin i will be changing the
order of the applications before us
today
the first application before us will be
thirst and then the hoxon will be second
and as i chair this meeting i will have
to stand down as chair
chairman of the meeting and hand over to
councillor hadingham for item number two
uh because hoxton is within my ward and
therefore i wouldn't be able to chair
this meeting
okay so the first next item on the
agenda is dc
2585 harvey's green plants great green
thurston
i'd now like to invite john patemanji to
introduce the application to the
committee
thank you chairman give me one moment i
will put the presentation on
it's just seems to be delayed
why is it not sharing
try one more time
can i confirm you can all see the
presentation
although be i haven't been on full
screen yet yeah it's it's up john thank
you
thank you
so this is the application for harvey's
garden plant a great green
thurston it's an application for one
dwelling and associated works
including landscaping and access road
so harvey's garden plants is at great
green first and
and uh if you can see my cursor
hopefully you can
garden i've got harvey plant the
harvey's garden plant is
in the top corner of your screen just
there
and this is great green as a whole and
just about the association this is
obviously
first and village we have the primary
school the
um the high school and rail connections
the site itself is now being shown on
screen
site areas 0.45 hectares isolated acres
and that's a close-up of the the site
we have some remaining parts of the
business but
the site itself is now vacant and you'll
see that on photographs in a moment
put this the great green into context um
it's within two kilometers
of the key surface settlement which has
shops and stores
and rail connections as i've said um
just to explain
on here this is the site just in this
point here
and from there i've shown uh three
routes
one being 1.35 kilometers in terms of
uh the purple to get to the settlement
boundary that way
the other in red to get to the
settlement boundary that's 1.98
kilometers
and i did deviate here to get to this
boundary
which is 1.66 kilometers in total to the
site
return this is a great green area um we
need to consider the site
not just as it is now but also various
approvals
that are currently capable of
commencement um
and these have been allowed through
decisions or appeals over time
so we have the site uh this is the
proposal
i've seen superceded on top of the
screen front view
we have um development on the opposite
side of the road that has been approved
now at the moment that's outline it
doesn't have the reserve matters but the
indicative plan
shows the three the four red blocks
there
we have another approval along uh
popular
farm lane and we have another one
further up that lane as well
uh that one's through appeal there are
various refusals
in the area as well i'm not and i've not
shown uh all of those
we have a current appeal case um just
here
coming going through as well um there is
also the
refusal and it's important to note this
one
uh and immediately adjacent and as part
of
harvey garden plants uh this
was uh dismissed at appeal it's for
application dc1800143
this recent appeal was very clear that
great green
is a sustainable location and not
isolated and performs a material
consideration
it was for two dwellings but it was
dismissed
on rural character it wasn't submissed
on sustainability
so the site plan is for is a full
application so it's
everything we have is in front of us um
this is for a bungalow
and unlike the adjacent site this is set
back
and closer to the remaining buildings
and parts of the harvey
garden plants use
it includes there's a adjacent barn
just on the screen here uh just a note
that has prior approval for conversion
into residential use
openness is maintained to the front of
the site
elevations so maintaining the rule theme
it's weatherboarded bungalow design
the garage follow suit with the design
again low level bungalow low level
garage
and this is uh what it effectively will
be replacing
the bungalow would replace this building
that's currently on site
which is no longer in use as you can see
the use of the sites is being
moved or has been abandoned at this
point
these are images just of the internal
area of the site
which would form part of the site that's
the barn
that has consent in terms of prior
approval for conversion in the
background
just outside this is harvey garden
plants entrance
which would lead round to the site and
on the left
we have where other approvals are
outlined at least at this stage
have also been given
taking it from the opposite direction on
the left-hand side this time is this
site and we have existing dwellings on
the opposite side
and the approvals for more dwellings in
this area
here
so in conclusion great green is a
cluster of dwellings and employment
be it a rural one it is well connected
to the
location of first and settlement in
terms of distance
the first and neighborhood plan was
adopted in october
2019 and form part of the development
plan
and therefore forms part of the material
considerations for the determination of
planning
policy one which is referred to within
the officer's report does deal with
housing development
in first and does state that new
development in first and parish
shall be focused within the settlement
boundary of the village
as defined in the policy maps it is
noted that this says development
and not just dwellings the site is
not within the settlement boundary as
defined by the neighborhood plan
policy one is not taken to be a cap on
development outside of
the settlement boundary if it was it
would be in conflict with the rest of
the development plan
for example policy cs1 and cs2 that do
allow a prescribed range of development
be it
these policies in themselves are also
deemed out of date as they do not fully
comply with the nppf
the neighborhood plan would if it was a
cap on development
would also be in conflict with the mppf
directly
that does allow residential development
in the countryside in in
different forms it isn't acknowledged
that the parish council do not agree
with this position
and this position has been taken forward
previously by the district council
on other development around first and
offices have also taken legal advice
as to those other cases on this
particular point
in simple terms the focus the policy
seeks to focus development within the
settlement boundary
but some development and it's far likely
to be less elsewhere than within the
settlement itself
is not restricted the underlying
principle being that the presumption of
supporting sustainable development
unless there is a material consideration
to consider otherwise
this development is not considered to
result in harm to energy
it redevelops a site it has limited
benefit in terms of economy
but there would be job creation there
were no highway concerns ecology or
other concerns
and on this basis the recommendation is
one of approval thank you
all gone quiet
um i don't know what's happening sorry
you couldn't hear that okay
uh so uh thanks very much john um if we
now just have any questions or points of
clarity
uh if people just put their hands up uh
robert can you just take me through
are there any hands up we have
councillor hattingham then councilman
councillor stringer okay let's go in
that order
please um thank you this is um
councillor hattingham
um john can you just confirm that this
um barn
well is it the is that the grey box
there is that the barn that's got um
planning
permission already or you know it's
going to have permission to turn into a
house
it has prior approval consent to be a
dwelling yes thank you
who is next um it's councillor muller
here um
uh chair um john can you please confirm
the actual garden center is either is it
still open
i can't confirm that i'm afraid i don't
believe it is to the public anymore i
believe there is a
uh substitutionary interest adjacent to
the site now that is
continuing but i don't know if they're
doing that just via mail order or
something like that
uh that might be a question you need to
ask the agent possibly the ward members
or the asian award members aren't here
today they're both
given written reps okay who was next
thank you chair uh yes to ask the
question
i'm rather confused about the statement
that the uh the national planning
policy framework it means development is
not
restricted outside the settlement
boundary i found that very confusing
so i'd like some uh clarification on
that that statement
i'm also very confused about this the
position of policy
cs1 cs1 allows
you were saying development outside of
the settlement boundaries but it's out
of date so we've got to ignore it
but if we've got to ignore it why are we
assessing
it uh it was my understanding that where
there was a
current neighborhood plan that basically
bolted
directly onto the national planning
policy framework
uh if if the local policies were out of
date
so let's get clara actually yeah
let's get clarity on those points no
problem
so paragraph 79 for example within the
nppf
allows for housing in the countryside in
various forms for example
uh barn conversions and it also allows
for
house to housing to suit rural needs um
so
the mppf is not prescriptive to say
anything outside of the settlement
boundary
doesn't it needs to be refused it
doesn't say that at all
uh in terms of cs1 and cs2
uh both are deemed to be out to date
because they are
um of an age that does not comply with
the nppf this was established through
uh various appeals not least the appeal
at woolpit that i'm sure most members
were aware of
um but we have a five-year land supply
at this moment in time so they are
got some weight but they cannot be given
full weight
in the context of that it doesn't mean
they can be ignored
they are material considerations and
they are
applicable uh in this respect the
neighborhood plan
does not supersede them it is part of
them in terms of being part of the
development plan as a whole um there
isn't a competition
uh ultimately though the neighbourhood
plan is given significant weight
on the basis that it is up to date it is
updated in terms of the nppf
however what i was talking about was the
interpretation of policy
one i would say that the policy is
certainly
significant and in date if it is not
deemed to be
a cap on development if it is deemed to
be a cap on development
then it is in conflict with the nppf
and by being in conflict with the mppf
would make it out of date
so i do not interpret the policy and we
have legal advice on this as well
as the policy is restrictive to that
extent that it stops all development
outside the settlement boundary
um that is the position of the
offices before you council stringer
would you like to come back yeah
yes i would you quote paragraph 79 could
you then tell me which
paragraph this complies with a b
c d or e
the other point of course is that our
local plan
is in part out to date and therefore we
are looking at that tilted balance in
terms of uh promoting development
and we have to look at this development
like i said before
the presumption is for sustainable
development unless there is material
consideration
otherwise and that is at the beginning
of the nppf in terms of the presumption
to support development
so in that context we have to judge this
on its merits
and whether or not it is favorable or
not in the context of whether there is
material harm
to balance that is where we are
okay any other questions at all
from members any other points of clarity
before we move on
yes please
yep okay so let's go in that order
please
okay thanks chair um
mr pokemon g you mentioned the um
planning permission that was rejected
for two new dwellings and you
you stated that um this was due to
um
bear with me sorry uh
location within a constant outside
sorry sorry matthew can you come back to
me i've lost my place in my notes
yeah i've yeah of course uh who is next
counselor i think that's okay
um yeah i i'd just like to to ask for
some clarification
um in that john payton g um said there
would be some job
creation by this scheme uh yet
the this uh proposed development seems
to be
on top of what was uh once a cafe
which presumably also had employment and
i wondered
uh if there'd been any um
investigation into uh you know
if the existing cafe had gone whether it
was it was ever likely to be
reinstated as a cafe
uh no your policies don't require us to
look at that
in terms of marketing or continued use
in the in the context of uh
trying to maintain that employment use
um there is a loss
of employment use in terms of this has a
a use but this is also
agricultural so this is a bit of a
unusual
combination it's not like it's a
straightforward industrial use
on this site and we can be very clear
about what maybe the loss of employment
could be
um i also don't know how long this has
been out of use for
um or the when the cafe closed
the cafe closed earlier this year okay
um in terms of job creation the job
creation is that one dwelling
is creating jobs in terms of
construction
and it also creates jobs as in you know
supplying people to the services in the
local area
but but the the job creation in terms of
construction is a very short-term affair
it is short-term um for one dwelling it
creates about two and a half jobs
in the construction industry for about
one to two years and then in terms of
the connection to services it creates a
further free
jobs long term that's according to the
2004
uh strategic uh growth plan which i've
got the reference to but i can't
bring that up without closing the
presentation
okay thank you councilman did you want
us to come back to you now
yes please talk about that um in the
planning permission for the two houses
were turned down for
being um not maintaining the intrinsic
character of the countryside
is it not also true that that um refusal
also went on to talk about
sustainability and i
quote involves reliance on the private
motor car is therefore contrary to the
sustainable sustainability objectives
and policy
fc1 fc 1.1 so is it not true that was
rejected
both on sustainability and um to
maintain a character of the countryside
it refers to it but it doesn't upheld
those as reason to refuse
um the reason to dismiss the appeal
sorry by the inspector ultimately
was the rural character of the
particular location and in this case
those
two dwellings were set uh in i
definitely see on screen
um within this section here of the site
um which is far more open than the
current site before you and therefore as
officers we feel that there is a
difference between the two sites
okay thank you very much thank you uh we
have another person who wishes to come
in
thank you chair we've got council string
has got his hand upside down i think i
might have been nick
i might have been madison and then
councillor field as well
okay councilman cancer food
right yeah this is this is council john
matherson um yeah presentational point
first the the history the planning
history
um i do find it difficult
that it's not in in chronological order
and i know this applies to both
applications actually
and i've forgotten what some of the
abbreviations mean
um like pde um
that's that's a a bit of a bit of a
problem
and um i think really somewhat similarly
with with councillor stringer earlier
paragraph 3.4 the development plan
for the area comprises a combination of
um
and neighborhood plan isn't listed i
would have thought it would actually be
the first one as it's the most
most up-to-date and recent one um
and um yeah i think
the can i just say that we're not we're
in questions at the moment
yeah sorry well yeah yeah you're right
if you've got a question
it's not a debate it is i think we just
heard that it is part of the
the development plan for the area
we've agreed that one question
yeah i can answer that just just to
mention that a pde
i believe is permitted development
inquiry um
and i do apologize i i now i've seen the
report um
they should the inquiries should have
been stripped out of the history they
don't normally get put
to members um anything from a pre-app
point of view is
normally mentioned separately and i
apologize that he's not in order
again i will take that back to my
colleagues and ask that we checked for
that in future
oh so that that i see that isn't really
of any consequence at all that one then
okay that's
that's that's a help um you have another
question
yeah yeah the other question really was
just to clarify
um i think somewhat with where
councillor mayor was going um the the
appeal decision
um which um didn't didn't
use sustainability as a reason
for dismissing the appeal that was
presumably before the neighborhood plan
was adopted
was it it was yes
all right thank you thank you thank you
very much councillor field you were next
thank you uh just a question really
about the engagement of the
tilted balance again i seem to have
heard that uh
argument in different directions on many
occasions
um whether whether it is in guys because
cause their policies are out of date or
not i wonder if john could just
uh go through that argument again for me
the argument in terms of the total
balance is engaged on this occasion it
is
housing uh development and is not in
and our local our development plan as a
whole is is not
entirely in date so on on that basis
i would say that our judgment is that
the tilted balance would engage
this doesn't respond to historical
assets
so it's not like the tilted balance gets
affected by that
it is a pure housing argument here and
uh
yes it is engaged and and
our our plan is out of date despite the
fact that we have a recently
in uh implemented neighborhood plan
uh this is difficulty um you're into the
judgment of
one plan versus another that is not the
case the neighborhood plan is part of
the development plan the local plan
the core strategy the uh focus review
are all documents that form the the
other development plan uh the fact that
one conflicts with the other
slightly unfortunately is is the case
here and
we have to take the whole lot as a whole
now as
the part of the debate what you decide
to give weight to
in respect of the relevant elements of
your development plan and that includes
the neighborhood plan
is for your judgment thank you
thank you very much any other hands up
please robert
we've got oh um okay oh sorry yep
councillor
haddingham councillor stringer councilor
madison and councillor mayor
okay so if you've done if you could take
your hands down but
first of all councillor haddington um
thanks um
so john scott a question about our
papers on page 112
it says site stick side six it's the
site layout is that the existing one
that's already there because it seems to
show what i thought was the garage
is a basically a house with bedrooms is
that
what's there now or um i'm a bit
confused
page 112 as i'm
remote working i don't have a
pay-per-click we i have to close this
project
same as slide six john slide six which
will help you
if i go back to slide six yeah that
shows the same
no that's slide six which is all right
in our pack slide six is different if
you go for
board one
no in our pack it says slide six it's
the site
site layout plan i just want to know if
that's the present layout which i don't
think it is but i can't
understand like i say it looks like
there's two buildings rather than just
one oh yeah yes no i in the in the
bundle
i think the uh original plan has been
put in there by mistake but the original
start to this application
was for two houses during the course of
the application it was removed down to
one house which is the slide before you
now so
the amended scheme is for just one
property
okay so just to be clear on page 110 of
our papers is what's before us now
what was previously came in uh but
hasn't gone anywhere is what's on page
112.
okay cool thank you thank you okay
uh cancer stringer did you want to come
back was your hand down
obviously i can't see yes yeah yeah no
no i've got i've got a question chair
sorry about this
um it's it's this geordian knot about uh
up-to-date plans or not it is my
understanding
and please the officers can correct me
if i'm wrong the nppf
is up to date the neighborhood plan
is up to date the neighborhood plan is
in compliance with the nppf
and those two documents together
do not trigger the tilted balance
so why do we insist on using an
out-of-date document
to then be able to invoke the tilted
balance
john i betcha because
you can't take the local plan
and the core strategy and the focus
review out of the equation
you can't ignore their existence they
are part of the development
plan so therefore they are part of the
development plan as a whole
with the neighborhood plan uh the
neighborhood plan is in compliance with
the nppf
entirely and it's a significant weight
because it is the most up-to-date
document in terms of both age
and it's compliant with the nppf um
it also says that uh development shall
be focused within the settlement
it doesn't say you can't have
development here though and that is that
is the key point
so regardless of weight the policy
itself is not regarded to be
unduly restrictive in that in the
context of this site
um if we go further in this debate
though i
would you're into legalities that i
perhaps need to
call upon other people to answer but
that's that is my understanding
okay uh any other hands up please robert
not like chair that's everyone okay
thanks everyone uh if anything comes to
mind obviously we can ask later on
just before we get into debate we now
move on to public speaking
uh i'll now ask the parish council
representatives council of western
councillor towers to speak
can i just remind you you have a total
of three minutes between you
to address the committee uh so if you'd
like to turn your campus if you'd like
you'd like to turn your cameras on
please
hello can you see me it's
yup we can now see okay it'll it'll just
be me
uh councillor west speaking on behalf of
the parish council
okay so there's only one speaker now yes
okay so you have
three minutes okay thank you the parish
council opposes this application for the
following reasons
msdc has already set a precedent for
refusal of numerous previous
applications for this area
on the basis that the developments are
in the countryside and isolated from the
main settlement
an applicant has lost an appeal also on
this basis
the development is outside the cartilage
of the settlement boundary contrary to
the made
thurston ndp the impact on
nearby heritage buildings the reliance
on the use of private car to access
any facilities in thurston stroke norton
bus services are very infrequent
and the nearest bus stop is over 200
metres away on a busy road with no
footpath
and therefore unsustainable there are no
safe means of alternative travel modes
such as cycle or foot access to
neighboring facilities
this will lead to the over development
of a small hamlet which will
fail to enhance protect or conserve the
environmental conditions or the
character of the area
and finally the relative ease should
finally be granted for a single dwelling
to further expand the development to
include further two dwellings
as originally applied for once the
precedent for development has been
established
the parish council is concerned that
officers in the development management
sustainable communities department
appear to be supporting the application
purely on the basis of not having to
defend
a possible appeal against a few a
refusal further down the line
not on the merits or otherwise of the
application
it has been stated that the officers
would rather support the single dwelling
application
than refuse the original three dwelling
application and risk having to defend an
appeal
however there is nothing to stop the
applicant from submitting a further
application
for more dwellings once a precedent has
for development has been set
this is a flood argument as a future
refusal could still be appealed
this is hardly an acceptable basis to
make planning decisions
the area planning manager has stated
that policy one of the first an ndp
is considered to be out of date because
of the use of the word focused
we can't accept this distorted
interpretation of a document that was
only recently adopted and further
approved by this very council
the parish council contends that the
made ntbs
should not be ignored by claiming that
the mppf
allows development outside the
settlement boundary the first in mdp
when taken in full paragraph 4.1 to 4.6
please read these is very clear with
regard to why
future growth should be focused within
the settlement boundary and the type of
development that may be considered
appropriate
outside the settlement boundary this
development is not one of those
the maid thurston ndp is therefore an
effective planning tool for applications
within village of thurston
and should be followed aside from the
major housing developments currently
under construction within thurston
the parish council is concerned that in
addition to the five current approved
major developments
the numerous small developments of one
to nine houses that have recently been
approved by
imsvc only adds to the cumulative
pressure on the local facilities
and infrastructure which to date has had
no investment whatsoever as a result of
any of the construction work
thank you thank you very much
uh do we have any questions please for
the parish council
robert do we have any hands that have
gone up
yep
okay councilor mayor first then
councillor stringer
um thank you um
the council the parish council are
against this development
are they against development on the site
as a whole in that
um very soon you're going to have a
derelict building it's going to look
unsightly
um do you not envisage any development
on this site
it depends very much on the type of
development the type of development that
is acceptable outside the
settlement boundary is set out quite
clearly in the
neighborhood plan if it was for that
type of development that is
considered to be acceptable then it
would be considered
could you could you just elaborate on
what that is
um i will have to refer to the
neighborhood plan
i think it'd be useful for your
committee just to know what's the
neighborhood plan
development proposals to meet specialist
housing and care needs on sites that are
outside the settlement boundary
will be permitted where it can be
demonstrated that no available and
deliverable site exists within the
settlement boundary
okay thank you very much councilman any
follow-up at all no thank you very much
thank you very much
uh we had another hand up
uh just yes that was me chair
uh you you mentioned that the site was
isolated can you
can you tell me where the nearest
footpath is to this site
uh there is no footpath into thurston
from this site there's no footpath
along that that road at all
you that's helpful thank you very much
any other questions for the parish
council
we've got councillor john matheson okay
councilman uh did i did i
hear um mr west say that there were
six types of development that were
acceptable outside the second
boundary he he mentioned one no not did
i mishear that
no i didn't say six i said there is
there are several types of development
that will be acceptable outside the
settlement boundary and this is one of
them
could you tell us the other ones that
are acceptable that's quite an
interesting point
examples will be care needs
local employment needs etc
yeah thank you thank you
okay uh any other questions for the
parish council
okay thank you very much for joining us
uh next up
um we don't have an objector uh or a
supporter that wishes to speak
uh so i'll now ask the applicant mr
james platt to speak you have three
minutes to address the community
that's the extractor policy one i can
put that up or go back to the position
you can leave that up but we'll go over
now to mr jones platt who has up to
three minutes to speak
over to you great thank you uh good
morning members
the policy position has been set up by
your officers in the accompanying report
i'll therefore focus my attention to the
general planning merits of the scheme
whilst the site is located in the
countryside it is however in close
proximity to thurston village
and the range of services and facilities
located there given the distance of
travel to the village
journeys by cycle remain a realistic
prospect for future occupiers
furthermore a bus service is also an
operation on alton road
providing an opportunity to utilize
public transport
the site is regarded as considered to be
a sustainable location
a view held by both the council and
planning inspectorate in the
determination of other housing proposals
within the vicinity
the application relates to a parcel of
developed lands set within the wider
nursery
the site is subject to a former cafe
building and areas of hard standing
previously used as a car park
and for growing and display of
associated goods in recent years
the business income has transitioned
from on-site custom to primarily
internet-based sales
to adjust to market demand the business
has adapted and phased out elements of
the operation
whereby sales are now by mail or order
only
in light of the changes that have
occurred the application site is now a
redundant part of the nursery
and has no real prospect of being
brought back into use
in this regard the proposal represents
an opportunity to make effective use of
the site
through the demolition and clearance of
existing development and provision of a
well-designed property
that is in keeping with the character
and appearance of the area in visual
terms
the development is to be to the
betterment of the site and its
surroundings
assessing the wider benefits of the
proposal the contribution of an
additional dwelling toward housing
supply of the district
is obvious and undeniable economic
economic benefits through the
construction phase and support of local
business will also be accrued
beyond this through the provision of
landscaping and appropriate measures
the proposal presents an opportunity to
enhance both the ecological
and agricultural significance of the
site something the applicant is
committed to once the comments from
thurston parish council and residents
are noted
it's highlighted that no objections have
been received from remaining consultees
including on those matters of ecology
highway safety and land contamination
considering the proposal in the round as
identified by your officers in the
accompanying report
to propose a sustainable form of
development whereby the adverse impacts
do not significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits
we respectfully ask members to approve
this application in accordance with the
officer's recommendation
thanks for opportunity to speak to
support this application thank you very
much uh do we have any questions
uh questions for the applicant
any hands up robert i can't see any
chair
oh counsellor stringer's just put his
hand up that's a stringer over to you
yeah um thank you for that you you
mentioned the
it's on a bus route can you how far away
is it from a bus stop
if you just bear with me i'll i'll um
i'll double check
so the the nearest route is on norton
road i'm just referring to
funny statement
john is that map going to help us so so
i approximate the site is within 150
meters of the site
and it's on norton road and the service
that runs for me is the 385.
okay so can you just show us on that map
before us john
where where we're talking about
so there with me hang on i'll just i'll
bring him up
um i've got him here updated sorry
if it would help i just would um it's
directed directly towards the
oak road which is um
the the the first sort of intersecting
highway
along northern road which is the main
road um there's a collection of
buildings that
um yeah okay uh
yeah sorry i just needed to double check
they were definitely operational as well
uh bear with me if we go back to the
presentation so essentially they're just
here
aren't they uh that goes off
so can you hear the bottom left-hand
corner where it says and mid-socket you
can see
the mouse there okay thank you very much
okay any other questions cancer stringer
all right okay uh anyone else robert
have their hand up please we've got
councillor
sarah mansell yep council
uh uh yes thank you i i was just going
to add to the bus information because i
too was looking it up um that the bus
stop there are three buses a day
to burst in edmonds and three buses a
day to stow market
from that uh bus stop okay thank you for
that
okay uh no other questions for the app
contra agent
okay thank you for joining us um now we
have representations from the ward
members
um now in my speaking notes it says that
members already have them in the papers
i would like i know
we always traditionally read them out uh
they're in the late papers that was you
received an email with the late papers
but what i would like to do is read them
out we always read them out in the
council chamber and i don't think this
is any different
so i know it'll take a bit of time but i
think it's important that we hear from
the ward members so
unless i'm breaching any code
i'm not okay thank you so uh
i'll do it in alphabetical order first
one is ha from councillor harry
richardson
dear all unfortunately i'm not able to
attend development can i just ask people
to put their mics on mute
i can hear some some background noise
thanks um
i'm not able to attend development
control committee meeting on wednesday
in which case could i submit the
attached as way of comment as a ward
member
and as well as sending my apologies in
you of not being able to attend this
committee
meeting in person i'd like to submit the
following written representations in
opposition to this planning application
this site is outside of the existing
settlement boundary and is isolated from
the rest of thirst and proper
this not only contradicts the
established policy within thurston's
neighborhood development plan
which emphasizes development within the
existing village
it is also in my view fails to align
with the key principles of the national
planning policy framework
firstly as this site sits so far beyond
the village of thurston
and any amenities or transport links
this development surely fails the test
of environmental sustainability set out
in the mppf
there are no practical means of public
transport available and no public
footpath or pedestrian access to the
main village
and so a dependence on cars to travel to
and from this site
is an in their inevitability as a result
of the mppf's policy of minimizing waste
and pollution
and mitigating and adapting to climate
change including moving to a low-carbon
economy
is directly contradicted similarly
as a single dwelling with no associated
affordable housing or tangible economic
benefit there is little wider advantage
offered to the district as a whole
there is little evidence of any
plausible improvement to the local
community
which another measure of social
sustainability which is another measure
of
social sustainability in the mppf and
given the large developments already
approved in thurston
there will be negligible improvement to
the economic sustainability of the local
area
furthermore i hope the committee will
take into consideration the previous
refusals relating to this site
specifically applications dc 18001
and dc1802262
as well as the rejected appeal apa 18
00250 which should weigh against this
development when considered against its
supposed benefits
for this reason i hope the committee
will agree with the comments made by the
parish council
by councillor turner and myself and
refuse this
planning permission for this development
that's from councillor harry richardson
next from councillor wendy turner who's
the other
ward member as i'm not able to attend
this committee meeting i'd like to
submit this letter in opposition to the
planning application cited
please accept my apologies for my
absence
i called this application to committee
because the proposed development falls
outside the
built up area boundary and beyond the
settlement boundary as defined in the
thurston neighborhood development plan
the ndp states that new development in
thurston parish shall be focused within
the settlement boundary of thurston
this is particularly relevant as
thurston has 1 200 planning permissions
already granted
with the majority of them in the core of
the village
there is minimal public transport
available and the proposed development
is situated on a winding road with no
pedestrian or cycleways into the centre
of the village
therefore this application runs contrary
to the nppf section
9 promoting sustainable transport point
103
states development should be focused on
locations which are or can be made
sustainable
through limiting the need to travel as a
resident of thurston
i can assure the committee that this
road is unsuitable for walking and
cycling
due to it being narrow and winding and
there are no street lights
this makes the likelihood of residents
walking or cycling to the center of the
village even less likely
and in consequence transport will be by
private vehicle
directly contradicting the mppf's policy
of moving to a low-carbon economy
precedent for refusal of this
development has been set up by the
refusal of planning applications dc
dc1905113
for the reasons cited in asking for
refusal for this application
mid-southwark district council as local
planning authority
hereby give notice that planning
permission has been refused for the
development proposed in the application
in accordance with the particulars and
plans listed in section 8
for the following reasons one the
application site is located within the
countryside
outside the defined settlement boundary
of thurston where new
housing is restricted in accordance with
the provisions of the policy h7 of the
local plan
the national planning policy framework
and the thirst and neighborhood plan
the proposed development does not accord
with the policies of these documents
in that the proposed dwellings would not
constitute one of the exceptions to the
restrictions on new housing
in the countryside as detailed in policy
h10 of the local plan
or paragraph 78 and 79 with the
framework
accordingly the provision of the two
dwellings in the countryside locations
where in the interest of protecting the
existing intrinsic character of the
countryside
there is a there is strict control over
new housing
sorry there's strict control over new
housing proposals and in allocation away
from essential facilities which would
involve reliance on the private motor
car
is therefore contrary to sustainability
objectives of policy
fc1 and fc 1.1 of the mid-suffolk course
strategy
focused review december 2012 and the
framework
paragraph seven eight eleven seventy
eight and seventy two nine
on this basis the development should be
contrary to policies gp1 h7 and h15
of the mid suffolk local plan 1998 and
policy cs1 cs2 and cs5
of the mid-suffolk ldf core strategy
2008.
the thurston neighborhood plan and the
national planning policy framework
thurston has a need for affordable
housing and not more large executive
homes on the outskirts of the village
i would urge the committee to give full
consideration to these reasons
to be consistent in giving the ndp due
weight
and to refuse this application
uh there has in the late papers also
been submitted a more detailed members
referral form
which has been submitted so that's it
from the
two local members who both sent their
apologies and can't be here today
okay members so you've had all the
details put before you uh you've heard
from
the parish council you've heard from the
applicant you've heard from the ward
members you've also had the late papers
um it's now open up for debate um
obviously we'll go through around let's
all each go through having the
opportunity
to speak and then once we've been
rounded around the uh
all around the room then we'll have the
opportunity to uh hear from a proposal
and take that forward so excuse me
i have a question i have my hand up it's
quite frustrating if you can't see the
hand
and that's the way we're meant to be uh
communicating with you
um i i just had a question that had
arisen whilst you were reading out the
comments from the board members i would
have finished those off before taking
the question anyway so that's fine so
your question please
i just wanted to get the question before
we started the debate yes go for it
um i i just have a question that is not
it's really for the for the planning
officer but it's just brought to mind
uh whilst you were commenting um whilst
you're reading out those comments
um and that is the application on the
other side of the road at
navaraq which looked like it was for
three or four dwellings
um could the planning officer just tell
me the date that that outline permission
was granted
uh bear with me i thought i put up the
date on there
uh 2019 it was october 2019 i thought
october 2019. okay thank you any other
questions councilman
sorry sorry can i just come back it is
important because the
neighborhood plan the first neighborhood
plan was adopted on the 24th of october
2019 so i'd like what i really want to
know is whether that approval
was before or after the adoption of the
thurston neighborhood plan
fine we'll just check can you give me
five i'm gonna have to go out of the
presentation
and i'll come back i can't let's go to
the important points
i'll come back out to come back to you
in a moment okay
sorry chair i i appreciate this is not
normally where the agent can contribute
but i do do have the date of that
decision in front of me
okay yeah yeah um yeah so the decision
was issued on the 20th of december 2019
so it was post adoption of the uh
neighborhood plan
uh that was sorry and to clarify that
was for one dwelling
um those applications were um where was
there were separate applications on that
site
okay john i think what we need to do if
there were separate applications can we
just have the various dates then
if it's more complex than just one
application
yeah bear with me i will grab that for
you
sorry i've got a very slow system here
it might take me a few minutes
i can i come back to you if you want to
continue and i'll come back to you very
shortly
yeah any other questions from
other members no i think john will have
to wait for this because we need it
before we go into the debate i think i
don't think we should start the debate
we've got all that information sure
would it be an appropriate time to take
an adjournment then um
just until mr payment has found that
yeah do you think it's going to take
that long john
that's a yes five minutes okay
okay 72 applications to find the date so
bear with me
excuse me sorry chip chair sorry i do
have those dates in front of me but i
don't want to sort of
you know i appreciate it anyway i think
we'll leave john to dig them out i think
that'd be better
yeah no problem okay what we'll do is
we'll start again the meeting and we'll
adjourn it and we'll start again at 10
40.
chair it's frustrating i've got my hand
up okay it's relevant to this
the actual date they're approved might
be irrelevant
if they were a for instance a committee
decision
and the actual approval came six months
after the decision
was made by the committee i agree and
that's why we need john to look up all
the information
exactly that's why we need to go john to
dig it up rather than just
take it um from from the agent just to
be 100 certain
i agree okay so we'll meet we'll just
have a quick break
let john dig out the information start
again at 10 40.
yes chair
[Music]
um
i'm not sure about that i the only thing
i could possibly suggest is
um signing out of teams and going out
and coming back in again
but it's not something we've come across
i'll report it to it
um no
no and it's it's only the only thing i
could possibly think is another option
could be possibly to connect
if you your connection doesn't seem to
be too bad though chair from what i can
hear
yeah so i yeah it might be a
possible glitch um but we'll i'll report
it and
see what um the it team come back we'll
see if they're aware of any other
instances of it
but for the moment if you're happy to
continue as it is cheryl
just relay
we'll now continue um and can i hand
back to john pmg so could you just run
through for us the questions regarding
the
uh application of the sites the dates
and i think as council stringer pointed
out we need the wider detail on the
dates in terms of
whether it went to committee et cetera
so could you just run through those
please
we're dealing with the land on the
opposite side of the site just put up
the relevance could you just put up go
back to screen uh the slide
six because i think that helps us thank
you okay
so um the the first one uh was which was
approved it was a delegated decision was
19
strike 2 2 2 4 for two dwellings
and that was approved uh delegated on
the 20th of june
uh 2019 so in respect of the two in the
front
we then had a further one come forward
on the 23rd of september
2019 again a delegated decision
that was approval so therefore we get
free and then the final one
which is just around the corner which is
the uh approval
for again a further dwelling uh outline
uh then a delegated decision again and
that was approved on the 20th of
december
uh 2019. so essentially you have one
after the neighborhood plan and you have
three before the neighborhood claim
thank you anyone have any questions on
that
no okay so members any other questions
anyone wants to bring up
no okay so we're going to debate um
happy to open it up to the floor uh we
can go through
the names alphabetically if people want
to or we can just do it by hand
i'm very happy do it by hand uh robert
you'll have to call each person out
please in order
who would like to start so we've got
councillor hattingham and councillor
muller
okay counselor having him first
thank you um i'd like to say i'm torn
but i'm not really i hate um anything
that goes against it
can i'm sorry could i just ask that you
turn your cameras on when you speak
i think that'd be useful thank you
okay um so yeah i i you know i i really
don't like this it goes against the
neighborhood plan which we've all been
on
encouraging our parishes to to complete
and to
to go against it within a year is is a
real kick in the teeth and i think with
next door
um their appeal being um refused because
of royal character
nothing looks like it's been um um
approved this side of the road and i
think the parish councillor had a point
when he said they could easily just go
for two more houses there as soon as
this is approved
anywhere i don't really like it at all
and that's my opinion
thank you who's next please robert
councillor mueller
councilman uh thank you chair uh really
i just really wanted to sort of
mention what's mentioned on papers on
page 86
paragraphs four one and four two
relating to a
previous appeal uh where the um
the appeal said i conclude that the
location would not be unsuitable for the
proposed development with regard to
whether occupants of the proposed
dwellings would have adequate access to
services and facilities
with an undue reliance on private
vehicle use
and 4-2 having regard to the inspectors
findings
and noting the application process a
single dwelling rather than two is
considered on a bill
it is concluded that the site represents
a sustainable location for the housing
density sort
but also on page 88 paragraph 10 1
under social and economic benefits this
said the scheme contributes specifically
toward housing need in thurston
noting that four bedroom bungalows are
identified as one of the housing need
types listed at paragraph
5.22 of the supporting policy text
in the thurston neighborhood plan thank
you chair
thank you for that and next up is
counselor maths and then counselor
mansell
thank you oh we want the video on
as well yes um
yeah the the i just looking at what what
counselor may have just just referred to
i did i did seem to to gather during the
presentation
when um mr payment he was talking about
the um the various appeal decisions and
so on
that that he emphasized
that the in in the appeal
the sustainability was discussed as
being
not not very satisfactory but it wasn't
used as a reason for appeal
and i'm i mean if you think about how we
we balance the various factors in in
reaching decisions
we frequently take into consideration
quite a number of more pros and cons
than than we necessarily decide
are asked strong enough to use
and state as the reason or reasons for
refusal
um with with one eye on on um defending
appeals inevitably
and um i'm a bit uncomfortable with the
idea that we
that the an inspector failing to use
lack of sustainability as a reason for
refusal
uh is not the same thing as an inspector
accepting that the the the site has
is adequately sustainable that's that's
not the same thing
in in my mind so i i think i've got a
bit of a problem with that and
i i the the i think the chronology
point that i made about the presentation
is that has actually rather come home to
to um to roost rather quickly
um and i'm i'm not clear there's several
different appeal decisions
um that we've got in in all of this so
i'm actually finally sorting that all
out a little difficult at the moment
thank you thank you very much casa
matheson
uh next up robert council mansell then
councillor field
councilman uh thank you um
uh i mean i i i finding this quite a
difficult decision to make
um because um it is sort of effectively
on
a piece of used land it's not like a
field in the countryside it is currently
uh got a business on it
um i regret the loss of the business on
the site because it did form
some employment in the area and i also
have my doubts
about the real sustainability of this
particular part of thurston
um and i i find that the the
um applications on the other side of the
road it's interesting that three of them
were made before the
neighborhood plan was adopted and then
there was a fourth one that was made
subsequently
um you know three buses a day along that
road
is not really a usable service for
people to get to work
um and the the map that the planning
officers showed us
uh gave us some distance to the edge of
the settlement boundary
not to where the services are in
thurston
um so it's over it's probably over two
kilometers
for people to get from this dwelling to
the railway station
where they perhaps could use some
sustainable transport to get
to and from work um so you know
it isn't really that sustainable a
location it is you know
one house and and and how much benefit
is this going to get from one more
house here when they've got over a
thousand that are already being built
uh or about to be built within the
center of the village so
i think it is a very difficult decision
to make i don't particularly like
it but i'm struggling to find
reasons that are going to stick out you
know stand up
for refusing it because um you know
if this if this adjacent field um the
inspector
thought it was just about sustainable
then it does make it more
more difficult to argue that this is i
mean personally i don't think it is
sustainable but
there seem to be a number of houses that
are being built around there which have
got permission
um and it's certainly not an isolated
area
there are lots of dwellings around there
but you know
you know being honest everyone who lives
it there is going to
rely on the motor vehicle and we should
really be discouraging that it's just
that we don't really have
planning policy strong enough to argue
that point
thank you for that uh next up was
councillor field
thank you yes
i do find a significant consideration
here is that we do have a neighborhood
plan
that we encourage parishes to produce
those because we think they have
significant value
and they are carry a lot of weight
so ignoring the neighborhood plan seems
to me
to be a problem there have been various
comments about
issues like the size of the house
suggestion that it actually does match
the neighborhood plans
uh analysis of need and
my own feeling that says actually to
keep
communities sustainable you need a whole
variety of house sizes you need
those for the lowest paid workers and
those for the highest paid workers so
we should be rather careful about uh
engaging our biases when we're making
those decisions
i guess i am concerned also about the
claim that the tilted balance is engaged
there are circumstances where it is but
we do seem to grasp that
as a tool to get applications approved
um and i feel that in this case
there is sufficient evidence that we
have
we have a five year land supply we have
a neighborhood plan
there are various things it implies that
it shouldn't be considered
uh the sustainability issues obviously
are
significant you might argue at the
moment that people are just as likely to
use something like teams to communicate
to work you know they
that doesn't engage your private car and
your private car in the future could be
electric
so that's to me a a somewhat weaker
argument i think at the moment i'll
listen to the rest of the arguments but
my feeling is that the neighbourhood
plan one is the most important one the
community has expressed its views
they're legally expressed they have been
approved and we should
give them very great weight thank you
thank you very much uh robert who's next
please
we have counselor richard mayer okay
thank you chair and when i
i'd like to thank councillor muller for
re just pointing out that paragraph 10.1
um that the thurston neighborhood plan
has identified
them large bungalows as one of the types
of houses they need
they've got 1200 houses built i'd
imagine most of those are
um two three bedroom houses
what we have here is is gonna be a
derelict piece of land
um but
i think what's the neighborhood plan
may um prevent or request
that nothing be built outside the the
settlement boundaries i think this
is an exception i think this is
justification indeed the um i think it
was council award
uh spoke about a special need well this
is a special need we don't need many
four-bedroom bungalows um
i dare say not many are being built it's
a special need
in probably a sensible position
in that um those occupying a house of
this nature
will have the necessary transport and of
course
with the cafe closing the amount of
traffic
is going to be reduced so um
that in itself is a benefit so whilst
i'm a big supporter of neighborhood
plans
i think actually you can argue that this
falls within
the neighborhood plan and that this is a
housing type
that justifies development outside a
settlement boundary
so i'm minded to approve
can i just check is that are you
proposing approval or are you just
minded to approve
well at the moment we're discussing but
yeah yes i'll be happy to uh
propose a later date if you wish
okay so i'll take that as a proposal to
approve but we'll keep going around
at this stage okay who's next please
robert
uh councillor john matheson okay
councilman
thank you chair the um i think
council of field very clearly expressed
um one one of the two points that i
wanted to make
when he spoke about the um the tilted
balance
being engaged rather to uh regularly
frequently
etc um and
um particularly in this context where
we've got a neighborhood plan
um not recently adopted
uh the other the other point that i su
i think talking thing we talk about the
the the
existing use um this is in effect
a change of use application uh from
from employment to residential and
i'm just looking at the um
the the the plan uh where there appear
to be polytunnels and so on
behind this site as to whether whether
an employment use
moving into multicultural and the
production of local food
might be might be a viable
future use of this site rather than
turning it over to um residential as
which has been pointed out there's a
thousand or twelve hundred
more to come already so i i think those
um
those points are not not encouraging me
to
to support this application and clearly
i i also agree with counselor hannigan
that the um
the principle of neighborhood plans does
need to be
defended by this committee
um where we have the opportunity to do
so
thank you
so much who's next please robert
uh we don't have anyone else at the
moment joe
well so far at this stage we have a
proposer but no
seconder anyone else wish to come in
i yeah sorry chair i i
i thought you were going through
everyone to hear their views
and then ask for a proposal yeah but
that
we've had so well no because no one else
had their hand up for review if you
would like to
come in i thought i thought you were
going through everyone in order sorry
no no
of doing that all just by hands up we
went with hands up so over to you
okay uh yeah uh just give me a second
uh yeah thank you chair uh why is that
not blurring that
uh all right there you go no not that
yeah it's just a second
that's better uh right uh yes just want
to i think this one isn't just cancer
stringer can i just come in because
just sorry to interrupt but it has been
pointed out to me obviously you've come
in
uh the reason it says suffolk county
council next to your name is because
you're using a county council laptop
absolutely but you are here as a
substitute only
as a district councillor thank you
absolutely yeah right
it's just the mid-suffolk supplied
equipment doesn't work
anyway the uh this one is a relatively
difficult one because obviously
trying to encourage single-story
dwellings in a rural area
is something that we wish to do
because there are certain people that
need single story dwellings
having said that you need them you need
the
right homes in in the right places and i
think what we're discussing today is
whether this is the right home in the in
the right place and also
i think it's a matter of sort of
planning policy and this is quite a
pivotal
decision i think today about how we go
forward i
i have to say i still really struggle
with this policy idea
that you can't you can't you have to
include
an out-of-date policy in your thinking
and because that policy is out of date
you trigger a tilted balance decision
when you have
two perfectly good policies that are up
to date
that should guide you with this because
they have the greatest weight
and the greatest way is the national
planning policy framework
and the neighborhood plan and if you
bolt those two documents together
because they coalesce
it helps you get to a decision on this
application
and the decision i come to with this
application is
it should be refused because the
neighborhood plan says
we should like a all of our housing
within a particular segment boundary
which is fine
and a mix of housing within that
settlement boundary if within that mix
we cannot adequately
get sufficient needs for special needs
that do arise then we would look outside
of that in those unique circumstances
the national planning policy framework
was argued by the officer
does not restrict development to inside
settlement boundary
quite true paragraph 79
lists all of the reasons and the
circumstances that you could approve
something outside of a settlement
boundary
and that is the essential need of a
rural worker
would make optimal viable use of a
heritage asset
would you reuse reuse a redundant farm
building
or would include the subdivision of
existing residential dwelling
or if the design is such exceptional
quality
that is truly outstanding with higher
highest environmental standards
none of those paragraphs apply to this
one
so actually i determine that this
application
is contrary to the neighborhood plan as
adopted
and it's also contrary to the national
planning policy framework
paragraph 79 if you do
invoke a tilted balance then there is
some policies that would support this
but frankly i think to use that argument
in this case
is wrong
thanks council stringer for that okay
uh looking around the room i believe
everyone has spoken except myself
uh i think all all councillors have now
spoken
i also um i'm afraid i'm not supportive
of this
um i think um
i think it's a it's a close run thing uh
i
i hear what council stringer says to me
we you know it's about giving weight to
the neighborhood plan over everything
else
and where do we rank it and how do we
you know where does that sit in the
decision-making process
um also i think it's about protection
the rural character
the houses that we've seen are on the
other side of the road
um to me it just
it just sits uncomfortably when we've
asked the parish to do so much work
and to come forward with the
neighborhood plan i think it just
doesn't quite
get it over the line for me it's a it's
a very difficult one it's a close run
thing
and my view is though this doesn't quite
fit for me and uh doesn't sit
comfortably
so that's everyone who wished to spoke
do we have any other hands up of
uh anyone else that wishes to speak we
did have chair
mr paytman g and then councillor mansell
and just to whilst i have
um the floor such as we do have a
proposal but we don't have a
second exactly that is correct at the
moment
okay so john pete mcgee you wanted to
come in and then we'll go to council
mansion
if i may just have a moment um
it's just just referring back to
uh power just very quickly referring
back to paragraph 79
um playing policies and decisions should
avoid the development of isolated homes
the the problem here is that phrase
isolated homes and it's fairly
established that this would
be a site that wouldn't result in an
isolated home
and of course this phrase has been
turned on its head and used an appeal
in the last couple of years to seek
single houses in the countryside and has
been used successfully to do so
so it isn't just the criteria that is
listed within a paragraph 79 but it
is that first phrase that we need to be
wary of uh if we were to hold a refusal
uh for a non-isolated property uh just
on that phrase alone
um my i i do understand that this is a
difficult one
it has been a difficult one for officers
if i can volunteer that
because there is such a different
balance to
undertake here we are within this remit
of a
neighborhood plan which we give
significant weight to but we are also in
amongst a whole load of appeals and
those
appeals are not consistent because they
are both uh allowing development in this
area
and also refusing development in this
area and we have
picked through those to come to the
on balance uh recommendation before
members so
uh it it is a it is a debate and it is
all down to what weight
members give elements my only
encouragement
would be that members should you know if
they are
looking against the development then
they would
need to be careful about what basis that
is being based on
my suggestion would be is to try to
clearly identify
harm in respect of the proposal
because that would be a stronger
position to take if that position was
taken many thanks
thank you okay so uh councillor mansell
uh thank you chair i i i too was
actually going to come in
on on a similar comment to what what uh
john palmer jesus just mentioned that it
does say in paragraph 79
it does refer to isolated dwellings and
as i said earlier
i can't i can't call this an isolated
dwelling there are a number of other
dwellings
in very close proximity however uh when
i look at paragraph 78
of the mppf it does say that
um to promote sustainable development in
rural areas now
i think we can argue that this is a
rural area
even if it's not isolated and maybe the
mppf is not clear because it talks about
rural in one paragraph and isolation in
the next
um but anyway rural housing should be
located where it will enhance
or maintain vitality of rural
communities i don't think
uh thurston is in danger of of uh
you know i mean it's got so many other
dwellings it does one more dwelling is
not going to enhance
uh the community of thurston so i
it's i don't to me it doesn't fit with
78 but i
i too have concerns about pinning it on
on paragraph 79
um because i don't think by any stretch
of the imagination
we can call this an isolated dwelling
but i do think that
i i think we ought to be able to use um
thurston neighborhood plan
uh policies because they do um say that
they
they only want sort of exceptional um
dwellings to be outside of their
settlement boundary
um and maybe that is a better argument
to use i mean i
i'm you know i'm not an expert but i i
would be concerned about about pinning
this on 79 when that talks about
isolated dwellings
okay thank you very much
okay robert any other hands up at this
stage yep we've got councillor field
castlefield yes on the neighbourhood
plan
issue um having said i'm concerned about
that
uh when john paintman g put the document
or paragraph from the document up
there were a set of criteria for
defining the acceptability of
developments outside the
the boundary and one of those i thought
uh
concerned with uh bungalows in
with uh good characteristics with with
uh
acceptable um environmental
characteristics or whatever i'm not sure
whether that's the paragraph that
councilman muller was
referring to but i wonder if we could
return to the document
and just look at that to see whether
this
this development actually fits that set
of criteria
because rejecting on the basis of a plan
that actually has a criteria
that might accept the development would
be somewhat worrying
yeah okay let's see can we put that up
john
yeah i i tell you i don't think it's in
that policy in terms of policy one i
think what we're talking about
is uh policy two in terms of meeting
thurston's needs
um i would i might be worth
with respect might be worth going
through the various policies of first
and neighbour plan
one by one if it would help members have
you gotten them there display those
yeah i can display them i can do that if
that would be useful
uh just give me a second to switch
displays over and then i can
do that again
that one
so let's start from the top um
is that large enough for everybody
um so that's probably there's policy one
um in terms of settlement policy
um so we've got
the um reference to policy two which
i'll come to in a moment
in terms of the needs of fersten
and we've got design high quality
buildings
uh retain raw character
and we have development proposals on
specialist housing and care needs on
site
and of course protection of agricultural
land if i
then scroll down to policy two
uh we are you know addressing the needs
of the wider housing market as a world
economy
um well it's there in front of you
um i'm conscious i don't want to
summarize this entirely in case i'm
accused of
being too brief with it so i'll let
members read
if anyone wants to come in as these
slides are going up just feel free to
come in if any members want to come
do you want me to move on to the next
that one through is a policy more on the
design elements of
a scheme which you may wish to consider
shall i move on yeah
yeah maybe okay
this one doesn't really relate
specifically to our proposals it's about
community facilities so i will move on
from that one
um key
movement routes again that might be
something that in response to
uh the site you may wish to consider
further
okay okay and
uh that's about highway capacity i would
suggest that it's
not applicable in this case although i
appreciate one extra house does provide
traffic um parking provision again i
would
argue that there was plenty of parking
position in respect to this
site and its location doesn't affect uh
drop-off for the primary school
um and policy nine refers to
landscape environmental features again
if we're talking about with
rural aspects
a development must be designed to ensure
that its impact on landscape
and rural environments dust is minimized
supports open countryside
okay i i think uh the power
that i was at the beginning of the
document
and uh i probably misread it so
there was one sort of early things you
showed
i would suggest i've gone through this
sometimes before that that's pretty much
where we are we have light pollution at
number 12 and we have
uh wildlife number 11 um
but you know i think we've gone through
the key ones yeah so can you just go
back to john's point at the beginning
just so we're clear yeah john
do you want to come in sure i think it
might be 5.22 that's relevant
okay it is 5.22 yeah
let me find
two
that's in order of need yeah so there
are certainly
a number of things they're
defining bungalows as being needs that
are
not otherwise being met
but i thought the paragraphs that were
referring to
criteria for allowing out of
settlement boundary development included
um something close to
what we are looking at but i believe
that i may have misread that when we
and then and the important thing about
this is this is the order
so you know everything is listed here
and that is the order of need
sheltered and then yeah
or i think we've covered that off okay
thank you
thank you john i think that was worth
just running through just to be
absolutely clear and that was the
opening one thank you okay
um take that down yeah thank you
okay who else wants to come in anyone
else
so we've got robert councillor stringer
then councillor muller then chancellor
man self account and then councillor
matheson
okay yeah and if i'm if i may it comes
back to the
that original question to the officers
about which
which policy in the national planning
policy framework then
supports this application
because you're you're suggesting this
isn't an isolated dwelling okay i'll get
that
so we don't use policy 79 then so which
one
supports it that that's what i'm asking
because when i
read the other support ones yeah it
doesn't seem to okay let's just ask
that get that point clarified john
uh right okay
the essentially support is deemed by the
opposite meaning
of that first paragraph in in terms of
paragraph 79
so if the default if you can't if
isolated dwellings
are not allowed the opposite is then
true that non-isolated dwellings
are and that is what's been used as an
argument
there are other aspects the whole of the
document the whole of the nppf has to
also be taken as a whole
and it is a presumption of being in
favor
of development unless other material
considerations
say otherwise so if this is causing harm
to amenity if it is causing harm to the
environment if it is causing harm to the
rural
character if it is causing harm to you
know highways
there then that takes away the
presumption
of development but the presumption is
there and of course i'm not i've got the
mpp have to head me here but in terms of
the first few
paragraphs it's all about the
presumption of growth planning is here
for the presumption of growth
um so what is stopping that and that is
what the mppf as a whole has taken i
don't know if ian wants to help me any
further because you were
uh witness to the council advice as well
in respect of other
sites within first and whether any
aspect of those could be helped
in this case but um without going into
it but ultimately it is members opinion
of
how much weight they give both the mppf
the current local plan
or indeed the neighborhood plan yeah and
how they interpret those policies
okay hello yes i i heard all of that and
there's not very much more i can say to
that i mean if i
the risk of prolonging things if i go
back absolutely to first principles we
all know members of this committee very
well know the statutory duty that
applies that you you determine a
planning application in accordance with
a development plan unless material
considerations
um say indicate otherwise i think
if you i think perhaps we will just go
back to that new as i think it's been
explained and everyone has got the point
that
the development plan is not one document
it's not it's
shouldn't be seen as one document in con
contradiction to others it is the
the the rel the policies as a whole
whether from the
um the the local plan and the
neighborhood plan where applicable as it
is here
as john says bolted on and then the
the the nppf is not part of the
development plan it is a material
consideration
i think having listened to council
stringer i mean i think this
is is that it's it's her majesty's
government's own fault because they've
used this phrase out of date but we've
had it
said in court numerous times in case law
that it it doesn't mean you totally
ignore a policy it means you attach
less weight to it it would have been
better if they'd said attach
less weight in the first place and it's
a matter for the decision maker on every
occasion
though of course the nppf is important
government policy that we would risk
being found perverse if we said we were
actually going to attach
very much less weight to it in this
context but i think yeah i don't i don't
think there's much more i can add to
john's point
it's if in a way if you're you're
it's i mean is there a specific question
that there
i think i think that covers it off i i
think i mean i think we're covering
uh repeated ground now and i think the
committee knows only too well of its
responsibilities and and how it needs to
weigh up the various parts of the
equation
and give which part weight that they
that's up to each individual member to
make that decision today so thank you um
okay i am keen to okay so we've got some
more hands up but can we not
i think we don't want to cover old
ground so who's next
is robert so we've got councillor muller
and then councillor manso and then
councillor matheson
okay councilman first
uh thank you chair i must admit having
seen um paragraph 5.22 which lists four
bedroom bungalows is fourth on the list
out of approximately
six um i think um that
potentially could sway the way i was
going to think on this particular case
uh and i think after the neighborhood
plan does have a considerable weight
uh so that was quite an interesting and
i thank john peyton g for actually
showing that
it's very helpful thank you okay thank
you councilman
uh thank you um now i i i too would like
to thank uh john for pointing out
all of the policies in the first
neighborhood plan
uh and because i think that um policy 6
a may well
to me i don't think this application
meets policy 6a because it says
new developments must ensure safe
pedestrian and cycle access to link up
with existing pavements and cycle
infrastructure
this development certainly does not do
that
and i'd also like to go back to policy
1d
of the thurston neighborhood plan uh
which says that it must meet
development proposals outside the
settlement boundary
um if they are to meet specialist
housing
and care needs and now we've seen that
list that was in paragraph 5.22
um and uh as councillor muller's just
pointed out
uh four bedroom bungalows were fourth or
fifth on the list
above um four bedroom bungalows were two
and three bedroom bungalows
so you could argue that it's it's uh it
isn't that
you know we actually need to actually
need smaller um
uh bungalows ahead of the larger
bungalows
uh and if we then go back to policy 1d
of the thurston neighborhood plan uh it
says that
even if even if that was one of the
requirements of
the community that they needed these um
four bedroom bungalows as
a specialist type of housing it does say
it should be demonstrated
that there are no available and
deliverable sites
within the settlement boundary for those
um specialist
needs so um you know i'm i'm
veering towards uh wanting to
refuse this application on the grounds
of thurston neighborhood plan
1d and 6a um but i'd just like to listen
to see what um
anyone else has got to say okay thank
you very much councillor matheson and
then i'm going to just
go back to councillor mayor
thank you yes 522 also
much much of that has been said the only
other point about 522
in the neighborhood plan is that um
people that want bungalows probably
would particularly want to be near the
services
um not a mile away from them so um i
i think um yes agreeing with with
several people
already that that the the idea that
it's a it's it's a meeting housing need
because it's on that list
um having seen where it is on that list
just above
extra large houses or something really
doesn't carry any weight at all thank
you trump
thank you council madison any other
hands up before i just go back
robert any other hands up nope no chair
okay
so at the moment we've had council mayor
who says he's happy to propose
the officer's recommendation councilman
over to you is that
where are you at and what do you want to
do do you want to stay with that
and take it forward or not you're over
to you
yeah it's very difficult um can
i honestly put forward that uh four
bedroom bungalow because it's number
four
on a list of six is sufficient weight to
overturn other parts of the
neighborhood plan i think on reflection
the answer is no so now i'd like to
withdraw the motion
okay so at the moment uh we have no
proposal
standing and we didn't get a seconder
which is why we're not voting on it
uh do we have any other proposals that
anyone like to bring forward
we have councillor stringer has got his
hand up and councilor muller
okay cancer stringer than councillor
miller thank you chair
yeah i think now having sort of read
some more of the mppf as well because we
that that is sort of the overarching
direction of government
and and paragraphs like paragraph 78
sets out that we should promote
sustainable development not just
development sustainable development
in rural areas uh housing should be
located where it will enhance and
maintain
the vitality of rural communities
this site could be argued well it's
relatively close to a bus stop with a
minimal
service would that enhance the use of
that facility
well it would enhance it an awful lot
more if it were in the clearly defined
settlement boundary
in an adopted neighborhood plan and
where it doesn't
fulfill the needs of uh
specialist groups to be where it is or
serve a business or
one of the other needs i i think we're
on slightly dangerous ground without
case law actually on on the particular
site we're talking about i know we've
got some case law around
it but i i i think on balance i would
certainly recommend refusal
basing it on thurston's neighborhood
plan
uh that paragraph six certainly a and b
i felt that it it was in complete
contravention of
uh and and also it's its overarching
policy about where settlements should be
i have some sympathy with what is
potentially a brownfield site
but then if we've got a brownfield so
it'd be nice to see the whole site come
forward
or if there was a dwelling here that was
linked to the business use that's there
a worker needed to be there to
facilitate that business
i would have more sympathy but at the
moment on balance
i i certainly would recommend refusing
and i propose refusal
on the basis of the neighborhood plan
first
neighborhood plan certainly uh policy
six a and b
and on the national panel policy
framework uh paragraph 78
thank you chair thank you and we have
had other points rose i think
policy nine policy uh i've written down
5.22 and 1d
but maybe we'll come on to those see
where we go and whether
you want to tie them in as well yeah i'm
happy with that yeah
okay thank you do we have a seconder
please
i'm happy to second chair counselor okay
councilman mullen um now uh john
payton g just before i i opened it up to
others we have
also talked about policy nine protecting
the rural
environment uh
no policy nines protect i've i can't
read my own writing
uh protect rural uh character
sorry character um uh and we've also had
policy 6a and 5.22
also mentioned on on the grounds of what
you've heard from council stringer and
others
can you just run through before we go to
possible reasons for refusal
just to clarify them for us please yeah
okay
um we've gone quite a few different
places in policy
and it might be just worth wrapping
those up a little bit um
please can i can i start with uh let's
start with policy let's
mppf everything's n
sorry the neighborhood plan first
neighborhood plan policy one
um okay so
the emphasis of policy one that is that
development should be focused within the
settlement boundary
well this is in contrary to that that
this is not a site within the settlement
boundary
so you can you know reasonably say that
it's
not in accord entirely with that
especially with the other
aspects that we're going to talk about
1d though has been mentioned
um developer proposals to meet
specialists housing
and care needs on sites that are outside
well
arguably a four-bedroom bungalow is not
a specialist
housing need or a care need
because there's no definition of what
specialist housing and care need
is in relation to this policy um
there you know there is no glossary to
this uh
and it doesn't get picked up in any
other way so i'm
a bit concerned that we're trying to
essentially
provide a criteria of what is a
specialist housing and care need
to meet this policy or not meet it as
the case may be
um so i'm i'm not
convinced that that would be a suitable
way forward
okay let's let's keep going through all
the various policies so then it's up to
council string and council merch if they
agree with the
with that yeah moving on to policy six
a um certainly um
if members are mindful that this is not
a
so trying to scroll to the right policy
um so this is obviously talking about
key movement routes
um and you know new development must
ensure safe pedestrian cycle access to
link up with existing payments
well that is not being proposed here so
clearly
it is contrary to that element of uh
policy six
so 6a it would be a clear uh contrary
matter so um you know i can understand
that
going forward um six uh a
b uh talks about
the enhancement of the key movement
route
i need to check this is actually a key
movement route
uh pages 75 and 76 bear with me
75 75 75 um
uh oh yeah it is so okay so
it's the blue line on page 75 of the
neighborhood plan and we have a key
movement route for judging device policy
six and that is the
uh the main road in front of this site
so going back to policy 6b
uh i forgive me for having to do this
incrementally
um this obviously says there should be a
contribution although i don't believe
any such contribution fund has ever been
set up
um it also says not have a detrimental
impact
on the key movement route so ultimately
we're saying that the flow of
pedestrians and cyclists
from this development of one house might
have a detrimental
impact on that movement route
possibly because there is no facilities
along that part of the route
for safe flow of pedestrians and
cyclists so on that basis um
i would say that policy six a and b
are applicable um in that context
right good so um that leads me on to
policy nine um i would suggest
which is a clear statement in respect of
uh
development must be designed to ensure
that its impact on the landscape and
high quality rural environment of
firstness minimized you're saying that
this development does not
minimize uh the harm on the rural
environment
and you know outer character perhaps so
you know you on that basis um you know
that would
perhaps pick up on the adjacent uh
appeal that had the same mind in terms
of rural character
um and i think that would cover the
uh neighborhood plan uh then i would
probably
suggest members consider that obviously
beyond the neighborhood plan we still
have our
uh be it out of date uh policies in
respect of the development
plan of the local plan core strategy and
focus review
and as much as you may not be able to
give them as much weight as we'd like
we can give them some weight and i would
suggest that policies
h7 cs1 cs2 cs5 which talks about
environment and rule environment
fc1 and fc 1.1 of the focus review
are still applicable and maybe wish to
be taken forward as well
does that help or do you want me to
summarize some sort of word
uh council stringer and council muller
is the proposer
and seconder for refusal have those
covered all the points that you wish to
raise
uh yes i think they have chair and there
was no comment about
quoting anything from the nppf yes
uh uh i think i think we should at least
quote one of the paragraphs
where this is in clear conflict with
yeah so
if i may come in on that one uh chairman
if i may uh paragraph 78 yeah well
you are making a judgment you know if
you feel that the location the sighting
uh design you know of the proposal
uh fails given the location to enhance
or maintain the viability of the rural
communities
um or fails to demonstrate this um then
being contrary to paragraph 7978
is your your position going forward
okay so council stringer you've heard
the reasons for refusal that have been
read out and the various policy numbers
and council miller are you are you
content that that is the reasons that we
should vote
upon which we should vote yeah i'm
content yeah
okay and counselor mueller yes i'm also
content thank you
before we go to a vote does anyone else
wish to speak
there's no one else there chair okay so
we will now go to
a vote um uh and i will now hand over
to robert carmichael to take us through
that
thank you chair so if you could please
respond with four against or abstain
councillor john field four fear
we're voting for refusal yes four
councillor lavinia hadingham four
chancellor matthew hicks four
councillor sarah mansell four
councillor john matherson oh
counselor richard mayer abstain
caster dave muller
counselor muller are you there sorry for
thank you councillor and councillor
stringer
four could you read up
that is carried by seven votes to zero
with one abstention
mr duprey do you confirm yes yes i agree
mr carmichael
seven votes in favor and one abstention
okay
so the application is refused thank you
very much members
so we now move on to the next
application uh councillor hattingham
will now take the chair
and as the ward member i obviously will
not be able to vote on the next
application
over to you councillor hadingham
thank you um can we um can i suggest a
comfort break for five minutes
and um okay cool so if we come back at
say 11
40. okay thank you
thank you
so we're moving on in the agenda to um
item seven
a um dc twenty zero one seven one
seven land east of abbey hill hawks in
suffolk and i will now ask the
governance officer to conduct a role
call to confirm all members have
returned after the break
thank you chair so
councillor john field president
castle hattingham present councillor
hicks
present council mansell present
chancellor matthewson prison
[Music]
and occasionally correct we're all here
chair
good thank you i now invite case officer
jamie edwards to introduce
the application to the committee
jamie or mute yeah turned it off there
you go
thank you very much thank you very much
members um yeah i'll take you through
this
application uh we're at land east of
abbey hill hoxton i'll just share the
presentation now so if you just bear
with me one second
while we wait for that to come up
you should all see that on your screens
now
hello can you hear me yes we can hear
you we've got it on our screen
excellent stuff perfect thank you okay
so we are looking at the hodgson
area up at the north part of the
district
this is a reserve matters application so
we are looking here at access
appearance landscaping layout and scale
just a bit of history and context on the
site the outline
application was granted in august 2017
under that following reference number
that you'll see on screen
the monument which will become clear in
a second as i go through the
slides is located to the east of the
site
and was listed after the outline
permission was granted
and that was listed about 16 months
after in december 2018.
so whilst this change is a material
consideration in the reserve matters
application
it does not void the outline application
permission in the first place so we'll
go through the details of the context of
the site in further detail now
starting off with an aerial map and we
will zoom out so you can see this
uh in in the setting but this is the
site plan
site area we've got some residential
development to the south
we have two residential dwellings to
the west and you can just see there the
white dot which i'll just put the my
cursor over the top to clearly identify
is the monument
hoxin is split into two distinct areas
we have the northern part
to the top here we have a gap where the
site lies within
and then we have the southern area here
this is just to show a little bit
clearer monument is clearly
identified there we've got the swan
in public house up to the north this
arrow here just
shows where the post office is we've got
the village hall here
and down the bottom here we've got
hoxson primary school
looking at some further details the
purple outlines
you can see one in the north and one in
the south
these denote the two conservation areas
these are polyfocal conservation areas
and we can see that gap in between and
you can see that we've got residential
development at the bottom of hooksen
hill here
a few here the two houses opposite and
the
abbey terraced semi-detached buildings
here
we've also got the settlement boundary
line in green for hoxin at the north
which is a countryside
village and then to the south it's seen
as a
primary village here
and just also to show the flood plain
areas and what you'll notice here is
abby hill which is the road that runs
along here is lower
closer to the flood plains obviously and
it goes uphill
to the south you'll also notice the
numerous different listed buildings
within the conservation area to the
north we've also got
a grade two star listed building here
similarly we also have a grade two star
listed building here
and a grade 2 listed building here the
monument just for clarification is grade
2
listed
this just shows the special landscape
area majority of which is to
the north into the northeast
and this slide here just want to
highlight is
the details in terms of this is abby
hill
road coming up this is the site and what
i wanted to just identify here is this
green dotted line which is the public
right-of-way
so that comes off the road goes back on
itself
towards the north goes across the top
here
eastwards then comes all the way back
ground and almost does a big loop if you
will
back onto abbey hill
you'll note that i've commented on that
prow in paragraph 6.3 and 6.6 in the
report
so site location plan that we submitted
you can see that we've got two accesses
which we'll go into a little bit more
detail in a second
just to show again you've got the two
neighbors opposite
the semi-detached buildings of abbey
terrace here the monument
located there in the line of development
and this area here is where the flood
plain comes in
and we've got a grade 2 listed building
in here as well
so straight into the site location plan
there's a lot of information here
uh inevitably it'll be a slide that we
probably go backwards and forwards to
throughout um
the committee um i will start by just
going through the trees
uh they mentioned quite a bit in the
report so at the bottom here we've got
the t1
oak tree the dotted line we then have
the t2 ash tree that is proposed to be
removed and i will go into that in a
little bit in a second as well
but just to continue with the
identification of trees we've then got
the t3 ash tree which is to be retained
and the t4 ash tree which is also to be
retained
we also have the addition of
the t5 t6 and t7 trees
and also the replacement ash tree that
will replace the t2 one that's to be
removed
now the reason that they're going to be
removing this tree is
simply because we need to make sure that
we have access
wide enough for the highway standards of
4.5 meters
to access the two plots three and four
now uh the original part of the
application
actually had this at a 3.5 meter width
access
which would then only access plot 4 as
per the highway standards and which
would mean that we could retain that
tree
however the subsequent issue with that
is is that plot 3 would then have to
come off the first
access and would also mean that it would
cross over the permissible path
that we will go into in a bit more
detail throughout this presentation
but it would then mean that we'd have a
driveway that crosses over so it's seen
actually to have
two plots coming off the one at the
spent expense of the loss of the tree
which will be compensated with a new
tree which over time will obviously
regrow
so just going into the plot details now
you'll notice that plot one has a wide
uh sorry a large floor space here that's
because it's a single story dwelling
and we also have an out building which
is a two bay
cart lodge with uh office space or study
room if you will
in there plots two and three are almost
mirror images of one another
and we have the detached garages or cart
lodges if you will
um either side of them and plot four
again has a an actually attached garage
in this instance
the next thing i'd like to bring your
attention to is you can see on the right
hand side of the page this denotes where
the
monument is located and what has been
shown here is
that we have a view through between
plots one and two
and we also have a view straight down
the middle
and there's some steps you can just see
it's indicated there so steps there are
some steps and we'll see on some
photographs of the site in a second that
lead up
and across the existing permissive path
across there
so a couple of points i'd like to point
out uh you'll see within the report
that whilst it has been noted that this
is
appreciated and it actually came as a
part of amendment of some existing
application
uh that was withdrawn where plot one
actually blocked this view
this is a view that we can make sure
that we can condition that no
outbuildings
no extensions no fences
can be erected within this area um
more readily across the whole site um
but what we can't prevent in this area
is planting we
someone who a future occupier of this
house could come in and plant hedgerow
down there that could block that
so i haven't given that as much
weighting in the decision making as
you'll see in the report
however what's key in this part is
this is been identified as a key view
and this view has been identified within
the
heritage reports that coincide with the
hawks and conservation areas
it's been identified as key view nine
and again that's identified within the
reports
um but what we'll see is as we go
through the slides that this view is
going to be interrupted or the setting
of this view is going to be interrupted
by this development in the first
instance but what we look at in the
report is that by the time we've moved
through the site
it becomes uninterrupted and
particularly when you get into this
stage
the monument is obviously going to be
uninterrupted from development looking
out
towards the north east east
and southeast
just making sure i haven't forgotten
anything on this i'm sure we will come
back to this slide shortly
so we'll move on for now just to go
through the elevations and plan drawings
plot one as said is a single story
dwelling
we've got some pictures on the roof of
making sure that we don't have any kind
of right angles in there
we've also got the single story
out building two bay with the home
storage uh sorry home
office which you all know is obviously
useful in the current times that we have
but also to identify that this is a four
bedroom house in this plot
we've got master bedroom uh bedroom two
three and four strokes study
this is we have some vertical cladding
and uh
horizontal cladding as well of the mix
and the pan tiles
move on to plots two and three again
these are images so what you'll see here
i'll show you plot three in a second
we've got the chimney
on the left hand side we've got the
windows at the ease levels
we've got brick plimps at the moment the
drawings are
dictating that we're going to have
render you'll notice in my report that
i've asked for a materials condition to
be added to any approval on the
application
as i feel that plots two three and four
it's probably an overbearing amount of
render and actually the plot could do
with some diversity and materials on the
external facing but that can be dealt
with as part of a condition
and again just to show the floor plans
we're looking at three bedroom
um houses for both plots two and three
so that's plot three and plot two like i
said they're identical mirror images of
one another
moving on to plot four oh so this is the
garage uh
detached garages for both plots two and
three as well so you can see that
now plot four is the larger of the
four plots and we can see again that
we've got the steep
pitch roofs we've got brick plimps
we've got and i've shown quite clearly
within the report the different sizes of
the different
uh ridge heights so we've got 8.4 meters
on this one
and you can see here that we've got the
attached garage on this side
again the floor plans again we're
looking at a four bedroom house on
platform
it's an indicative land gate scheme in
regards to the permitted paths at the
moment is just a permissive path
is recommendation and we do have a
section 106 in with our legal team at
the moment that are looking at that
draft
that will secure this path input
perpetuity and guarantee
access to the monument out the back for
all public
members of the area and
what's key to sort of denote here is
you'll notice within the report i've
talked about a 13
meter buffer and the fence line that's a
post and rail fence that's proposed
coming across to here to here
the 13 meters is from here to here
so we can actually see that we've got
some additional buffer outside of that
area as well
and again this has taken some uh
amendments through different schemes
that have had conversations with
ourselves planning authority for a
pre-app
and also understand some informal
conversations via email to the parish
council which i'm sure they'll let you
know about
at the vote part to speak
um this here bonded shingle is not
happening
apologies i've taken this from a
different drawing but this will be
a pebble kind of finish non-bonded
reason for we need to make sure that the
site is still permeable because what we
don't want to do is exacerbate any flood
area risking
uh to the north which i showed you on
the maps as well
and again just to note that we have got
post and rail fencing
all the way along so we've got
traditional agricultural fencing
throughout the whole site in between the
plots
okay moving on to a street scene section
here we can see the symmetry between
plots two and three
um kind of giving you an indication here
and the orientation which we will see
again on that
block plan it's kind of given an
entrance to the monument at the
rear of the site with that buffer area
at the front
we can see that the t2 tree has been
replaced we will be replacing it with
another tree which over time will grow
we've got the oak tree in front of plot
four here
and the t4 ash tree that's existing
here and the new trees that will be
planted
as part of the scheme we can just see
here that we've got abby
terrace which comes along this isn't i
just wanted to make clear that this line
here isn't showing the line of the
the houses at all it's actually just the
telegraph poles
and the wires so so don't get that
confused that it's trying to denote any
type of line of rich heights or anything
like that it's not doing that at all
and we've got some street scenes uh
sections on the other side so plot four
looking through it
and we've got the houses on the other
side i'll point out which one grasmere
house is it's the modest out of the two
plots that are opposite and then
obviously plot two showing the
stairs i might just be able to zoom in a
little bit here
so you can see the existing uh the
stairs that existing
and the grass where that goes through
this is the path with the
hedgerow so the post and rail that will
lead out to
the monument there's a substantial
buffer still between
where the end of the plots are to where
the monument is in its settings
go through some photographs i've got
quite a few here so i will try and
uh not um scan through them too quickly
but if there is any that we need to go
back to just keep an eye on the slide
numbers and i can easily get back to
them for members okay
so this is looking from the south
looking north
abbey road you'll see here comes up to
the plot and then it goes
off to the north west downhill
and we're currently standing here
looking in this direction so we can see
the rows of abbey terrace here i've just
pointed out this arrow here there's a
gap
kind of um in the tree lines there
uh i think it's quite reasonable to
suggest that we're likely to see plot
four come above here
but it's not necessarily going to have a
huge impact on the kind of character of
the street scene as we can see that
they're quite prominent the roof scapes
as you go along there anyway
this arrow here is just noting where the
entrance to the steps are so it's a
clear indication
and we can see quite clearly there's a
verdant area in front of the site
so just moving along again keep an eye
on here where these photographs are
taken from
we've got the oak tree in front of us
here we've got the
t 2 tree which is to be removed it is
quite substantial tree
and then we've just got the uh t3 tree
which is just coming out there
which will become more prominent uh
within that street scene
with the loss of this one
and we'll just quickly pop back there
you can just see the start of the stairs
there
okay so we're standing right in front of
it um i think this is a kind of
unfortunate photo actually because we do
have a
large amount of shrubbery uh that is
actually blocking the monument currently
from this position
i can guarantee you if that was just cut
out you would see the monument quite
clearly
and you'll notice as we go through
that's the shrubbery that we were just
talking about and the monument is quite
clear there
moving a bit further into the site we
have
a mode area at the moment approximately
a meter and a half
two meters in width and the monument is
obviously there
we've got shrubs overgrown shrubs in
this area
this field currently is agricultural use
it could be cleared it could be plowed
and crops
grown on it so there's a monument
um it basically represents uh an oak
tree that fell
you'll see there in august 1843
it was seen or presumed that that oak
tree was perhaps the
oak tree that saint edmunds was martyred
up against
and there is uh tales that a arrowhead
was found within that tree when it fell
in 1843
the statue wasn't actually erect or so
the monument wasn't actually erected
though until i believe 2001.
just a bit of context on that so
basically got my back to the monument
here and looking out you can see the
modest
grand smear that i indicated on the
sectional drawings
and we also have the rose mount house
here on the right hand side
and these just show the trees that to be
kept in green so that's your oak tree
they're the two ash trees ash four and
two and then that is the ash
two oh sorry ash three and this is ash
two that is to be removed
and replaced so a few more photos
standing at this uh the top of the
stairs and we're kind of looking
down abbey road hill again look if you
see in the top left hand corner where
the photo is taken from
let's have your road hill there cyclists
just going down there now
you'll notice here that we've got a
cluster of buildings um
to the north which are just off picture
at the top here
but these start to show where the
special landscape area which is mainly
by
covered in trees from this point in the
flood plains
so we just skipped down abbey road hill
and we're now looking back up
you'll notice that we have the pathway
on this side and the road on this side
the next slide that we go to will follow
up the road but i will come back to the
path
i've out i've just put an arrow there to
denote where the monument is
um those with with good eyesight on site
will be able to see the monument
in this position um but you would have
to look out for it but it is there
this picture doesn't necessarily i mean
cameras as everyone is aware makes it
difficult to see but
um on site you can see it if you've got
good eyesight there
so just moving up the tree uh up the
road we can see that we've got the
verdant areas
that are blocking the monument in this
sense um and and do be aware that
obviously this is
uh summertime that these photos were
taken i do have a couple of clips taken
in winter time that we will flip back to
so make sure that we don't have any
uh bias of site visits that have taken
place in different times of the year
um but obviously this time of the year
you can't see it what i would note here
is that you begin to see
and is likely that you're going to see
plot one emerge here but we are going to
have those trees that are in front of it
so the street scene from this sense
is going to continue to have a verdant
sense of urden character
and again keep in mind where we're
taking these photos from uh
it's this part that i've talked about
plot 3 becoming
um apparent in this this view here
you'll probably see the principal
elevation of plot three coming in here
and plot four to the right hand side of
it
giving us the orientation of direction
of where the monument is located
let's get back over onto the path now
i've got a couple of photos here so
and this view coming straight across
abby hill road and across
this view is going to be lost plot one
is going to block that view as the
monument i think
is important to make sure that that's
clear
and again plot one is likely to make the
monument which you can just see on the
top of the fence line from the road view
will be blocked again but as we move
up the road a little bit further this is
where and i indicated on the map
on the block plan that that view will
then come apparent again through the
site
and i think it is important again to
stress that whilst we can condition to
make sure that we don't have any built
form fences our buildings extensions are
like in that area
we cannot prevent boundary treatment
such as hedgerows being planted
in that space but i think what is
important
the key
at the top of the stairs and we're
looking directly north again at that
cluster
we can just see the public right-of-way
sign there which shows
the public right-of-way runs down
towards these buildings and we can see
obviously the special landscape
area like i said which is the flood
plain and the verdant grass
sorry verdant trees that we can see in
full bloom there
i've also got some photos obviously
taken earlier on in the year
you can see now this areas we've had
some photographs showing what was in
full foliage
uh is now got no leaves on it and again
that special landscape
area greenery is quite obviously lost
there
you can see the public footpath a lot
more clearer there and this tree in
front of us is the t4 tree
that will be retained and the t5
6 and 7 trees which will be planted
along this boundary here
so again earlier on in the year i
believe these photos were taken in
january
and again you can see the scale and
massing of the house is opposite
the modest one to the left-hand side and
we can see here what the
plot currently looks like in these times
and again uh it's a shame i haven't
taken this
photo two meters to the right so we can
see it in line with the steps with
which is is the views that have been
talked about um but there's the monument
in its full glory
uh the permissive path that currently
goes along there
will obviously be secured as part of the
section 106 as part of a public benefit
that's been outlined in the report
and this photo also just to make sure
that we're aware that we've got the
context of the site this was taken in
2017
uh back when the outline permission was
granted uh we can see that we did
actually have an agricultural field
in this instance and the permissive path
is nothing but
uh kind of walking through the the
shrubs that are on that field at the
moment
and last photo here is part of what was
submitted as the
um statement with the application
this is what plot 4 will is a picture of
what plot four could look like
plot one and plots three and uh two and
three
so just to
conclude based on the planning balance
outlined in the paragraphs of the report
11.1 and to 11.6 of the committee report
it's considered the positive ratings
clearly outweigh
those given to the negative impacts and
recommendation is to approve this
application subject to the conditions
within the report and the section 106
agreement which is currently with
our legal team as the draft thank you
very much chair
open to questions thank you very much
jamie that was really um thorough
and i've also just had a note from john
payment g to say that it's not for um
blank approval it's for grant approval
which is in our
um our papers so um questions from
members let me just um
have a look at the hands see who's
first so i've got sarah mansell
uh thank you chair um um i've got a
couple of
queries uh but first i would like to
thank um
jamie for a very thorough presentation
um i thought that was excellent um
uh my first question is about the
uh boundary treatment between plots one
and two
um you said that there would be a
condition that would prevent future
people
putting a fence there but we can do
anything about the trees but what is the
current boundary treatment that is
proposed as part of this
application because presumably there is
something between those two plots
and my second question um
is about the um expiry date
of the outline planning permission um
which i presume that there's obviously a
the time limit is is is about i don't
know whether it's about submitting the
reserve matters
or getting some reserve matters
through and what the implications are
should that
lapse yes of course thank you very much
um i'll start with the boundary
treatment question
uh the whole of the boundary treatment
where you cannot see
the planting of shrubs and hedgerows
is the one meter post and rail fencing
or metal estate fencing again which we
can condition
um i think ideally we would like to see
the metal estate fencing in terms of the
traditional
um post and rail that we ordinarily
would see
but i don't think that there would be
any adverse impacts if it was a timber
post and rail but we can condition that
to make sure that we've got full details
uh after an application if it was to be
approved and that essentially is
all the way along around all of the
boundaries so we can see the blue line
is behind that red line that indicates
the post and rail fencing
it goes around each plot and it also
goes along the permissive pathway
which will be secured as part of the
section 106. so hopefully that's a
little bit clearer
in regards to the expiry date i
understand that the
outline application is due to expire on
the 25th
of august 2020 the conditions that are
set mean that they only have to submit
the reserve matters application so
should it be deemed if it went down this
line that the application should be
refused today
they can submit they can appeal that
decision also resubmit a new application
tomorrow or between
now and the 24th of august and we would
have to consider that application
uh as it is submitted i hope that helps
uh thank you for that um so if
if if for instance um there was a
recommendation for refusal from this
meeting and they then resubmitted
another application
it would have to be before the expiry
date the august date
um but if if it lapsed then they would
i mean there's nothing to stop them
reapplying
for the outline or putting in a fuller
planning application presumably
yeah that that would be correct i think
if this if this one was refused today
they could obviously
appeal it and that appeal could take
place outside of the the lapsing of the
outline
application at the end of august but
again they could submit something
tomorrow they could submit something on
the 24th of august
so long as it's submitted to the app um
to the
local planning authority it doesn't
necessarily have to be validated as long
as it's submitted
and then they have met the tests of that
condition that was applied
to the outline thank you thank you
um thanks um next one up is i'm john
field
uh just a couple of points on the
monument itself
um i i understood it was put up around
18 whatever 30 something when the tree
fell
down you implied as you went through
that it was much more recent than that i
just
would like to hear that clarified um
the other we know it was um
listed in 2018
do we have any view about uh any
evidence at all about the number of
visitors to this
monument is it um you know something we
we've seen a lot of comment from local
people that that they
they're very sensitive about their um
inherit their heritage but uh
have we evidenced that this is a big
tourist attraction so
large numbers of people appear regularly
or or not
yeah just going to your first question
thank you councillor i stand to be
corrected if i am wrong and i apologize
uh because i know there is local
interest in this monument my
understanding
is is that as it shows on there monument
itself if i just zoom in
the tree itself fell down in august 1843
and the uh you can't quite see it on
here but it was part of the hawks and
millennium project
to erect this and i believe was in 2001
again apologies no
can hear someone's voice there sorry
chair i really don't want to be butting
in but
i do feel it's important
at this stage you can speak and when
you're three minutes sorry about that
okay
okay apologies sarah and uh
i will stand to be corrected on that
i think the key thing about this is is
that it was listed in 2018
uh in terms of your second question
council field
i do not have and have not been provided
any evidence in terms of numbers or
tourism
uh numbers that come as a result of this
but i do know that it is an attraction
thank you um so john matheson next
hello um the this there's two things
look at looking at the um looking at the
monument there i would take take a guess
that we're gonna hear that actually
um the the the old the old monument was
re-erected on us on a
finer plinth um in 2001
i i'm guessing but my question really
was that
i don't quite understand how if the
outline
permission regarding archie archaeology
was explicitly in order to inform our
decision today but it's not been carried
out
um i i can't quite see how
we we're being being asked to wriggle
around that
um original condition or whether one of
the officers can explain that a little
bit more
yeah happily answer that for you
counselor um
so just to elaborate the original
recommendation for
a condition on the outline application
was for the investigation works two
archaeological
um interests to take place prior to the
submission
of the reserve matters now that wasn't
what the condition was worded
on that uh unfortunately that that's out
of my control
as an officer at this stage but what we
have looked into
uh is that that condition
is strong enough to ensure that we still
have control
over any outcomes that come as a result
of uh
archaeological investigations so if i
put it like this if we granted the
application today
for approval based on this they would
still need to discharge that at
that condition in regards to
archaeological
investigations on the outline
application
should that and i've spoken quite length
with the archaeological officer at
suffolk county council
should we deem at that stage that any
findings that have happened as a result
of that
investigation would mean that let's say
that and it was
described to me it would have to be of
national interest that we would need to
uh preserve what is in the ground and it
should be showcased uh
if it wasn't to be removed and put into
a museum and it was to be showcased
within the plot itself
and one of these houses was on top of
that we would be able to prevent this
layout taking place as a result of that
condition not being discharged so we
would say that we are not satisfied
that any findings as a result of that
archaeological condition
would conflict with the design layout
plan should you approve today
so we're quite satisfied that that
condition would still control from the
planning authority's point of view
anything that could be found of national
interest and that was the key part of
national interest
i think yeah if i could briefly come
back and i mean that that is reassuring
that if if the builders um
dig up the bones of king edmund or
something
um it will call a halt to that plot
being built there
um obviously the
the wording um was unfortunate
at the time and perhaps in the cut that
context
can we can we ensure that what you've
just told us
is is somehow on the face of the
permission should we decide to grant it
uh yeah i happily put an informative on
to any decision
if we were minded to grant the
permission today and that informative
would just
outline that there are conditions that
would still require discharging on the
outline permission
prior to commencement of development and
i think that's key because
we've done a lot of conditions recently
where they're prior to commencement
development above slab level or prior to
commencement of certain parts of the
development
this condition that is on the outline is
explicit in the sense that it is prior
to development full stop so they can't
start development
unless that condition has been
discharged
right thank you that's that's helpful
thank you
thanks okay we've got councillor richard
meyer and then councillor um
hicks thanks chief just a quick one
um the path is currently a permissive
path through the site
and then across the farmland the public
right of way will that be through the
site
to link with a permissive path across
the farmland or will it be a public
right-of-way all the way to the monument
okay so the prow
that is currently and i'll just jump
back to this
slide here which shows it a little bit
better it doesn't go through the sight
at all the prw
and neither does it go to the monument
it goes around
around the back of the uh sort of wider
field that the monument is within and
and just to sort of note that whilst the
road here
it slopes up slightly to the monument it
then does sort of
slope and level out and plateau towards
the prw at the back
the permissive path that currently goes
through the site as we've seen on the
photos and i'll just go back to the
block plan it's easier
uh is is permissive at the moment we can
all go out there and walk across that
field to access the site
but what this application would do is
secure this in perpetuity
as a public access right away across
there and that's not to say that it's a
public access right away that would be
taken up by suffolk county council
as a pub prow in the same sense that
this one is
but it is one that would be secured
either to the maintenance of plots two
or three
uh or to a maintenance company or
should their negotiation
be successful then it might be a case
that the parish council wanted to take
it on so they have control of that in
the future
um the section 106 has been worded my
understanding after seeing a draft
that all three eventualities could take
place but only uh
one of them would happen one of them
would take place
uh under that section 106.
thanks thank you thank you i've got um
council hicks would now
like to answer the question thank you
i'd just like to go back and ask a
question more about the archaeological
position that we're in uh so condition
seven and eight on dc
1702868 conditioned archaeological
investigation
but we're sort of waving that and we're
saying because something's happened
could i have a
opinion from our legal officer because
if a condition is put in a previous
application that's not
carried out what is the validity that
has been carried forward on this please
uh ian i'm happy to answer uh initially
if you wanted to come in as well um
are you there was for a second i was
sorry madam chairman i was muted but
i just i think hopefully i can be heard
now and i yes just saying
let jamie go first and then i'll add and
add anything if i need to
yes the the reserve matters in the
outline application if
if if approved today would be paired
together they would still need to
carry out the duty of discharging all
conditions on the outline application
before development could commence
those investigation conditions
are the standard investigation
archaeological conditions on the outline
application
the only difference was is that it was
recommended at the outline stage that we
changed the first sentence to say that
prior to
submission of the reserve matters that
wasn't implemented by the officer at the
time
uh hence the reason we're in this
position uh but we're still satisfied
that they cannot commence without
discharging the outline application
conditions uh hopefully that that's
answered the question in did you want to
add it
yes no i i agree i don't think there's
anything more needs to be said unless
the council hicks
still has a concern
counselor i mean this feels very unusual
i mean it doesn't it it makes me feel
slightly uncomfortable and i'm just
trying to understand if something said
something should be done prior to
something happening
well then it isn't actions yeah
shall i add in i mean this is a very
uncomplicated area of law a lot of
people say unnecessarily when you
have conditions on a planning commission
there there are
some that are technically
pre-commencement conditions where
if you commence development without them
the development is actually unlawful
and it might well if if it's there a
long time it might become immune but
there is cases have gone to the supreme
court and back again
over whether something is truly is a
pre-commencement condition or whether
it's just one that
if it's breached you have to serve a
notice saying sorting out now
so i think um i'm happy with jane that
jamie's answer is giving you um
the correct position on this um
there is nothing more you can say in the
light of that jamie i don't think well i
will just add
that if if we kind of pluck uh the
scenarios which could come forward
let's say that it is approved today and
development started and they hadn't
discharged that condition
we would have grounds that our
enforcement team could prevent and stop
developments going any further for them
to be able to actually discharge
that condition and they would have to
take out those thorough investigations
in terms of archaeological
uh detailings we are satisfied and i
have checked
that should they submit an investigation
of works that has been carried out
and we've looked at it and we've said
you've found something here and we think
that this is
national interest we would not discharge
that condition
if one of those plots or one of those
houses in that
current layout which which could be
approved today
um overlaid it or impacted it
and that would have to be seen on a
case-by-case basis as that condition was
discharged at that time
are you happy cancer hicks well you know
ish
i'll discuss that later thank you
okay counselor maya you've got your name
back i'm your hand back up
okay sorry i haven't put it down all
right and the same is that
saying go for you counsellor um um
madison did you have a question i have
put it down now actually all right
so is there any more questions for the
officer
okay so we shall move on um
we have so now we move on to the public
speakers
i mean the parish council representative
sarah foote
is now going to speak and she has three
minutes to address the committee
thank you chair sorry for interrupting
earlier and i wonder if i could
correct the point of error that um jamie
made
yeah before i start my three minutes um
the monument was commissioned
by edward kerrison's daughter who was
lady of the manor in 1907
and constructed in 1908. i would hate
any of the members to think that it had
only been there for 19 years that is not
the case
and i know jamie will stand corrected
thank you thank you
thank you thank you all okay so in 2017
your council did not have an up-to-date
local plan and could not provide a
five-year land supply
an outline planning application was
submitted to build on greenfield land
which divides the two conservation areas
of hoxen
the site is outside of the development
boundary and home to a grade two listed
building it's at edmonds monument
which is of great significance to both
hoxton and suffolk
the parish council along with other
statutory consultees and numerous
members of the public
requested refusal of the outline
application
despite what should have been perceived
as a controversial application
and dealt with as such by your scheme of
delegation it was determined by one
officer
the parish council remains of the
opinion that if mid-suffolk district
council had been able to deliver a
five-year land supply
the permission would not have been
granted today the parish has had to
accept there will be some development on
this unique site
what the parish cannot accept is the
scale and design of the detailed
application
and how it has pushed the outline
permission for up to four dwellings
to the extreme hence the parish
council's recommendation to refuse
this recommendation details the
unacceptable size
and scale of the proposed properties and
their proximity to
and detrimental impact on a grade two
listed building
and we today ask for you to make the
same decision
there are many principles of the mppf
which this application is contrary to
they are listed in our written
representation but i will refer you to
the two most relevant
paragraph 130 i quote planning
commission should be refused for
development of poor design that fails to
take
opportunities available for improving
the character and quality of an
area there are no character elements
presented in this application
the proposed dwellings could instead be
built in any housing scheme
anywhere in the country rather than
using the listed monument as a key
design feature the scheme turns
its back on the monument blocks the
uninterrupted views and as such is
highly detrimental to the villagers
heritage
para 185 i quote plan should be set out
a positive strategy for the conservation
and enjoyment of the historic
environment taking into account the
desirability of new development making a
positive contribution to local character
there is no evidence that the
development can anyway have a positive
or sustainable contribution on the
historic environment in which it will be
built
we would ask for consistency of decision
making
an application for development opposite
to this site was recently refused and i
quote jamie edwards
the proposal results in the loss of the
site as an undeveloped area
forming part of the setting and
contributing to the significance of two
conservation areas
and would considerably suburbanize the
rural setting
this detailed scheme for abbey hill
represents
maximum gain for the developer and
maximum loss for the village
you can mitigate some of this loss by
voting today to reviews this scheme
thank you thank you very much um
we have um one question at the moment
from councillor john matheson
thank you um you you mentioned
um the effect on on on a listed building
can the office or you clarify which
particular um one
we're talking about on them on the on
the plans
yeah if i may council matters in it uh
it's an edge of the monument if you look
on the historic
thing is a grade two listed building oh
oh sorry yeah
okay yeah yeah and so i thought i
thought we were referring to one of the
other buildings
there are a list of buildings in the
vicinity but i was referring to the
greatest building okay sorry no thank
you
are there any more questions for the
parish council oh john field you've got
your hand
up
thank you it was just my view question
again really about
um how popular this is what how
significant it is as a tourist
attraction if you like uh the the small
amount i could read
yesterday sort of implied that it's by
no means certain that this is uh
uh the scientists and edmunds execution
martyrdom
uh but it may well be uh does that
attract
large numbers of visitors to this area
um so
we haven't yet assessed really it's uh
yeah sorry if it matters it's subjective
what you call large numbers um radio
suffolk broadcast live from the monument
on the 20th
of november last year in edmonds day i
would say
most days you spot someone in the field
taking a look at the monument
the monument is part of the hoxton
hyster historic walk
scheme um so there's a map in the
village tourists walk around to several
sites of
significance and the monument is one of
those
so it is known thank you yeah
are there any other questions so we'll
move on to
the objector we have mr rob marsh farley
here
yeah thank you chair um can anybody hear
me
i assume you can hear me um yes this is
three minutes okay thank you uh yeah
this site
is obviously not just an ordinary field
it's incredibly important to the village
in several ways and to the legend of zen
edmond
it forms an important rural gap between
the village
which is split into two parts
the site is also well outside well
outside the village boundaries
gained approval for up to four houses
not four houses up to um
and the location of the access
originally approved was so poor
in the original scheme it has now been
moved
the application therefore before you
today
is to consider the layout design
scale landscape and including
access the current design is described
as appropriate
and linear in form as it matches the
local area
this is not an appropriate form for this
specific site
it is it creates a wall of development
virtually with no gaps mid suffolk has
lots of examples of developments
that the layouts have often been set in
semicircles
creating a green in front of them like
wingfield
horum whirlingworth and many others a
layout like this would create some
symbolism
to the approach to the monument the
current scheme
does not create a sense of place nor
recognize the importance of the monument
it goes to shield it from public view
the scheme goes further to diminish the
significance of the monument
by framing it between two garages and a
sea of car parking
the design of the houses is completely
inappropriate
in design and scale it offers nothing in
the way of design quality
nor reflect the local distinctiveness
which is a key point within the nppf
to put scale in context one of the house
houses
is similar in scale to the village hall
one of the most prominent buildings in
the village
the nppf is a powerful tool to enable
sustainable development which is why
this outline was granted in the first
place
when mid-suffolk did not have their
five-year housing supply
it is also an essential tool to promote
good quality design and where schemes do
not present
quality design they should be refused
there are very few houses of the scale
that are proposed
in this village um these are all
set well behind significant hedge
screening and trees
and if this was done on this site to
shield the
scale of this developments it would
further
gain to isolate the monument from the
village
an alternative approach to create a
front would enable
the houses to be built and create a
sense of space
and place but welcoming the villages
uh and the visitors to the monument we
have a great opportunity
with this um it's just gonna be your
last sentence please
oh okay um the scheme fails to achieve
and realize the opportunities given
within this outline
application and the scale is way
inappropriate
um and given the rural nature of the and
character of the site as it is
it seems impossible that this scheme
should go ahead in this form
thank you thank you very much do we have
any questions for the objector
right i can't see any so we should move
on to the applicants i'm sarah roberts
um so you have three minutes to speak mr
roberts
thank you um do you want me to put the
video on as well
please
right um
as you know i'm sarah roberts the agent
i was the agent for the outline
application
um and now for the reserve matters
application which deals with the design
of the approved scheme and outline
we started with an informal pre-app
inquiry on this site in march 2017
which was prior to the pre-paid service
which
is now in place um outline permission
was granted for the four dwellings
um the principle of development is
established on the site
um and so we're now as has been
previously said dealing with appearance
layout
and landscaping and the the entrances
which are more or less in the same
place as shown on the outline the
reserve matters application has now been
through a separate formal pre-app
route as well including a meeting with
the planning officer and the heritage
officer
the main issue with the site as raised
by local residents is the perceived
impact on the victorian
cross within the agricultural field 30
metres behind
our site during the reserve matters
design process
we engaged with the paris council and
widened the front
of the central open space to ensure
clear and improved views to the cross
once the visitor is at the top of the
roadside steps
we've had a section 106 agreement
prepared
to ensure the vista and path through our
site will be tied into the permission
with a minimum path width of four meters
at the rear and wide frontage of 13
meters at the roadside
this portion of land is available for
gifting to the parish council in
perpetuity
once landscaped to the parish council's
requirements
the parish have indicated their interest
in this arrangement
hence the draft 106 to secure it
but that is still up for final approval
by the parish council themselves
it should be noticed it noted there is a
further 30 meters from our site boundary
to the monument which is outside our
control as one of the councillors
um inquired about earlier the current
permissive part
through the field to the monument has
always been subject to planting and
plowing seasons
i visited the site in 2017 when the
whole of the
field was planted with beat one of my
photographs was was shown in the
presentation
there's never been any formal track or
path here this is another
there is another formal public footpath
around the field which still offers long
unblock views to the monuments
to the monument um pre-application
responses from the planning officer and
heritage officer confirmed they would be
comfortable with the four metre wide
pathway
as this affords good separation and
clear views to the monument
there is an opportunity here to greatly
improve the approach to the monument
from its existing state
including a managed verge and small open
space frontage
with a wide path to create a sense of
place and to frame the monument from the
road
the heritage officer commented in my
view the reserved matters
proposals with the amended dis
amendments discussed can be supported as
having neutral impact on the setting and
significance of the monument
and of the conservation area and
resulting in no harm to heritage assets
and the proposal will allow the
opportunity to secure the path
one that allows the unveiling direct
site and appreciation of the monument in
perpetuity
via a legal agreement this will ensure
the enjoyment of the monument can be
obtained in the future for both the
residents and visitors
i consider this to be a public benefit
that's the heritage officer
in terms of layout and design the
site layout basically reflects the
traditional village ribbon form of
development but the two
can be your last sentence please all
right
um the two
um just a note about the archaeology
that the just to clarify the
uh the condition was for was a
pre-commencement condition
if the condition as written on the
outline was not a
a pre-reserved matters submission
condition
but um but obviously i can answer any
questions on my other notes
thank you very much do we have any
questions for the applicant
for the agent i've actually got one
which i probably could have asked damn
jamie
is the field owned by the same by the
same um landowner as the
application site
i think that the field is owned by the
farmer
which um and i understand that the
application site is in
is in a separate ownership is it part of
the farmers family
is it anything to do with the farmer i
can't answer that i'm afraid
okay thank you um i think that the
parish
council is familiar with the farmer and
i don't maybe it's something that they
should bring up they should raise
directly with him
all right i now have a question with
from um councillor john field
just on the issue of the um
archaeology it seems fairly obvious that
if this site is indeed
the site of the execution of a king of
england there might well be some icology
around
perhaps a shed load of arrows if nothing
else
uh could you explain why no action has
been taken to
to yeah yeah investigate that and give
us
a better basis for our decision yeah i
can explain
why um we
get getting permission on sites
is a is an extended and and costly
business
and until we until we're sure that
um the site is going to be able to be
developed
then it's a it's a big undertaking for
um for a um for a developer
to undertake archaeological works at
risk
if the uh if permission on a site is not
secured
we had a site in wortham um where um
the archaeology ended up costing almost
three hundred thousand pounds
um so that it's a it's a question
of of risk management and it is
um it's preferable for us to
establish that the site is actually
going to be developed and then carry out
the archaeology rather than the other
way around especially as um
and up to this point the um the
the the ownership is still in the
original ownership so it's
it's a question of risk management and
making sure that we are actually going
to be able to develop the site and then
carrying out the archaeology
i'll say thank you but you have got
outline planning permission which i
thought
established a principle and when i got
planning permission for
a set of football pitches on a site of
an old workhouse
i can assure you the cost of archaeology
was nothing like the one you just quoted
so i am somewhat surprised
because it would have made these
decisions much easier
well the um as i think the planning
officer pointed out
the uh the results of the
of archaeological investigation will
um either if the condition can't be
discharged then the development won't go
ahead if the archaeology
is such that it would prevent
development then the development won't
go ahead
it's not um it's not getting reserved
matters
doesn't mean that we don't have to carry
out the archaeology we will have to do
that and it will still have to be the
condition will still have to be met
and the archaeology will still have to
be assessed and
um if there's anything there it will
have to be dealt with
i don't want to labor the point but
clearly had you done the archaeology
we might know that this is an ancient
site
and if it turned up nothing we might
just be suspicious that it wasn't
so i'll leave it there but uh
um thanks for this john um i'm john
payton and she would just like to come
in at this point
uh yes i sorry to to interrupt i i think
we
need to be careful here in terms of um
going into the archaeological
uh condition ultimately at the end of
the day
suffolk county council archaeological
team did not
seek to refuse the outline planning
permission based on lack of information
or risk of discovery
at the time of that application the
application before us is a reserve
matters application
for landscape layout scale and
appearance and access
the control in terms of
the archaeological condition is in place
and you know we have the power to
enforce that that is
totally within the power of the local
planting authority
and the assumption must be made by
members that we shall do so
in order to uphold the outline planning
permission
i would be just a little concerned that
we are trying to unpick that
essential condition that is embedded
within the outline
for which this is a reserve matters
application that is an extension of that
outline
thank you excellent i always just have
one more question
from sarah um answer sarah marshall for
you
sorry thank you um just i i just want to
get my head
around the um possible results from
any archaeological survey that is
carried out um
because um maybe i misinterpreted what
the planning officer
was saying um that if if after you've
done the archaeological survey you find
some something significant um it will it
stop
all four of those dwellings being
built in the positions that they are
currently
or could it be that if the only
significant remains
are under the plot of one would the
other three
still be able to go ahead i'm not sure
if this is a question for
the agent or whether it's a legal or a
planning matter
um because obviously um the
the layout is as we see it has four
houses in
uh if you upset the balance it may have
a different effect
so i just want to know if should there
be something significant found are we
going to see
maybe one being redesigned or all four
of them being redesigned
yeah i'm happy to to try to answer that
question for you
um i think hopefully you can see the
block plan on there as well
i think what's uh an important factor in
answering that question is
what would be found until we actually
know
if it is an arrow in the top right hand
corner and that is nothing else
or whether we've found a thousand arrows
and loads of other stuff
coating across the whole site i think it
would have to be proportionate to what
is actually
a result of the investigation works and
until we know that we wouldn't really be
able to say yes or no today
whether or not uh plot one would have to
be completely redesigned or cut out
completely
or whether all four plots would have to
be removed completely
um i think what is important here is is
the conversation i had with
um archaeological um our colleagues in
south african council archaeology
department
was it needs to be defined as national
interest
for something to be so substantial that
we would result in uh
redesign of the site
uh thank you for that um i think yeah i
think that's
sort of answered my question but there
are clearly a lot of unknowns
yes hence the reason luckily the or not
luckily the
the condition still controls those
unknowns so we will know those
prior to them being able to convince the
development i think that's the key
indication here
can i may i just come in just on that
last point as well um
this is not an unusual situation um
ultimately
we have many uh archaeological
conditions imposed on development and
i'm not belittling this site by any
means
but we have these uh imposed in this
form
and in this time in in the same sequence
of time
in respect of various uh applications
for housing across the district
some of which are close uh closer to
list of buildings or groups of list of
buildings and
you know grade one list of buildings
where it is deemed appropriate because
of the risk that has already been
assessed to outline stage by the
archaeological team
that they are looking to impose a
condition rather than
stop the principle of development being
proposed
and they are satisfied that they can
deal with what they may find
at the at the later stage um it is
you know so we need to see this in the
wider context as well as
the local considerations thank you bad
job
thank you for that comment as well thank
you
um councillor manson do you still have a
question oh sorry it's gone
do you still have a question your hand
is still up sorry i forgot to take it
down
okay have we got any more questions for
the um for the applicant
okay thank you very much we'll now move
on to the more board member counselor
matthew hicks
to speak uh thank you very much
and thank you members oh sorry matthew
can i interrupt you to ask you do you
know
if the um the fields and the site is
owned by the same person
i don't know um so thank you members i
don't really want to dwell on the
reasons that we're here today and the
the controversy around the sorry i'm
someone is talking
can someone just turn their mic off i'm
getting i'm picking up a voice thanks
um i don't want to dwell on what
happened in the past outline permission
has been given it was extremely
controversial at the time i wasn't the
counsellor then so it's before my time
but this is no doubt a historic location
that suffolk should be
proud of and there has been clear
delineation
in the past between the settlements
within oxen and i am extremely concerned
that this will
cause harm to that setting so the
application before us is for houses
that i believe are of unnecessary size
and scale
and form but i'll come back to that i
firstly want to touch on the proximity
of some edmonds monument to this
development
and this is a crate grade ii monument
and the development does not protect uh
either the natural
or the historic environment um and in
fact i think it makes the
layout and the access and the design and
the approach to the monument
far worse because it will be blocked by
these proposals
so as the parish council has said in
their report rather than using the
listed monument as a key design
criteria and working with it i think the
current design actually turns it back
turns its back on the monument and
blocks
what is uninterrupted views of the
monument
and so is actually highly detrimental to
the heritage of this village
now there has been as the parish council
has said earlier results from local
housing needs in hoxen and that suggests
actually there's very little demand for
four-bedroom houses
there is demand for two-bedroom
properties so it's a shame that the
opportunity hasn't been taken to meet
some of that housing need
but the overwhelming scale and the
overwhelming height of the proposed
developments
is totally out of character i believe
you've seen the pictures of the houses
being proposed
they could be anywhere between romford
and uh elsewhere in the country are they
suffolk proud do they look like suffolk
design
are they appropriate that's for you to
consider and whether the scale size and
design is appropriate
um i don't believe these houses bring
any environmental impact to the
to the um site either we should be
building things that we're proud of
environmentally
the development reflects should reflect
the design of historic oxen and the
importance of this
uh two parts of the village uh that we
have where this is in the middle of it
all
the mppf paragraph 124 is clear
the creation of high quality buildings
and places is fundamental
to the planning and development process
and what should be achieved
good design is a key aspect of
sustainable development
i don't believe this is good design
paragraph 127 of the mpf says planning
policies and decisions should ensure
that developments and are visually
attractive as a result of good
architecture
layout and appropriate and effective
landscaping
could you point out what is good
architecturally about these or the
layout
it is we're supposed to be sympathetic
to local character and history
paragraph 127 says that's really
important
this is our history it is suffolk's
history
that needs to be considered and
paragraph 130 of the mppf talks about
planning permission should be refused
for development of poor design
that fails to take the opportunities
available for improving the character
and quality of the area i would argue
that is the case in this
occasion and finally mppf paragraph 185
says plan should set out a positive
strategy for the conservation enjoyment
of the historic environment
um i don't believe this does that either
so i would argue there are multiple
reasons why this doesn't add up and
stack up for us today
um it is it is not about perceived
impact which is what the agent said it
is actual impact
and these houses create one large wall
of dominance which i believe undermines
the and is inappropriate in this
location
you've heard the parish council accepts
outline permission has been given
and something will come forward on this
site but i would question as to whether
this
is the this is the design that is
appropriate on this occasion
for such a historic location that
suffolk is very proud of thank you
thanks very much um do we have any
questions for the um for the
the board member
that looks like a no um
so um so we'll move on now um
to um debate sorry where am i
so yes i'll open up the item to make
debate if you wish to make a proposal
after we've gone through the first round
debate please use the hands up function
okay so um who would like to start
or should i just pick a name sarah
thank you chair um i am
i think you know i think it's a bit
regrettable that we are where we are
really with this application site
um and and we've heard quite a lot about
um the archaeology and the fact that
suffolk county council were quite happy
at the time of
granting outline permission that they
were satisfied that
the condition that was imposed at that
time um
what was good enough but of course i
think we have to remember that at that
time
um mid suffolk didn't have its five-year
land supply
um and and we're talking about we often
talk about the tilted balance of
of uh you know what are the benefits and
the disc benefits
of of a any planning application
and at the time that the outline
planning permission was granted
um there would have been a benefit that
we would have got more houses to
fill the need from our housing our lack
of housing land
supply so um i think
um i i i think you know the
the whole archaeology of the site this
is clearly going to be
you know it's quite likely to have some
significant um
archaeological finds in that site
i think it's a shame that the condition
was was worded in the way that it was
but
but we are where we are um um but i
i really think although i have we have
to accept that
this plot of land has got um
permission to have up to four houses on
it i don't think these are the right
houses
for this particular plot um as it's been
said by
by other objectors and the ward member
um they they do nothing to enhance the
um uh surroundings of the
monument and the listed building uh nor
do they do anything to enhance
the character of of hoxton village in
fact they
they appear from local local perception
that there is harm to the historic
setting
and yet we've heard from the heritage
officer
um there's no harm i'm a little bit
confused about that because we often
have
uh what's called less lesser substantial
harm
and i would say that this is certainly
harm even if
the heritage officers admit that it's
less substantial
um in this case i think that's a very
subjective
view um and i really don't think that
the design
and layout of this development is
appropriate to its setting
i'm sure uh you know okay we're gonna
have four houses on here
they should be um designed in such a way
to enhance
the historic setting um and and this
does not do that at all
so i will await to see what other to
hear what other
um members have got to say about it but
i i
you know at the moment i am unlikely to
support this because i really do think
there are enough paragraphs in the mppf
relating to design and heritage that we
could pin
a refusal on but i will wait to hear
what other people have to say
but it should the need arise once i've
heard what other people say
i would be maybe able to make
make a proposal thank you
you um jamie do you want to come in now
i see you've got your hand up
yeah if that's okay chair thank you very
much um a couple of things i just wanted
to to point out
firstly in terms of uh the comments from
the heritage officer you'll notice in my
report that i have not
said that there is no harm to the
heritage setting um i've actually taken
the comments
of the other consultees and local
community and said that there is less
than substantial harm to the setting of
the listed
monument and i've shown clearly within
the conclusion of the balancing
how i feel in this application how that
is weighed with the public benefits
i'll leave that obviously decision up to
your sales members throughout the rest
of the debate about uh
whether or not that's the right decision
to make or not the other thing that i
just wanted to point out is is that
in terms of a layout we have looked at
different layout options
um we had comments
come from the objective regarding kind
of a splade type
layout we felt that that would end up
with residential immunity impacts to the
existing dwellings to the south of
abbey terrace um and we
we felt that we had made many amendments
to the application from the start to now
to get to a proposal that is acceptable
in terms of
layout it might then fall that the
members then still believe that the
scale maths and design of them outside
of that layout remit
is is still a reason for a refusal i'll
leave that open to the debate
but i just wanted to add that we we have
looked at alternative layout options
and made sure that this layout option is
one that gives us the benefits of the
views
and without having residential impacts
overlooking into
gardens of existing dwellings thank you
thanks
um councillor stringer
thank you thank you chair can you hear
me
yeah good good uh yeah this one is a is
a really really
delicate and and difficult one and it's
we are often in this position where a
previous decision possibly
didn't include what it needed to include
to get a sustainable solution in the
future
that doesn't mean to say that that we
shouldn't take everything that gets put
before us and scrutinize it
well and make sure everything's
consistent with the policy position
we find ourselves in this
this one is as i said very very
difficult and the officers just actually
i
had already just written a phrase
earlier on that the officer just said
that the the layout i don't think i have
huge issues with where i do begin to
get uncomfortable is with the scale and
mass of the design
if you i get very bent out of shape
about the heights of things
and how imposing things can can appear
and when i if you look at an average
house an average house is between seven
and seven and a half meters and
roughly 100 square meters in in floor
space for the average three-bedroom home
we now find buildings here that are
taller
and and yeah in some cases almost twice
the size of a
normal domestic home uh so
the outline did say up to four
but if you think the average home is 100
square meters you've actually got 600
square meters of development here
of living space so it actually is
is not up to it's actually sort of gone
beyond in terms of it matting
i i'm really i hate
i hate to say it i quite like the way
the bungalow looks on the side
uh i think that looks very appropriate
in that setting
as it goes further to the right i then
get more issues
the on on your plan plot 4
looks like it nestles quietly with abby
terrace
but in fact of course the ground slopes
away and it is significantly
taller in height than abby terrace so
i i personally think and we we owe
a huge uh debt to the future to get this
one right
we must get this one right because if we
get it wrong
okay former kings of england have been
dug up from under car parks so
you know but we really need to get this
right i have
i am really disappointed that
archaeological work hasn't actually gone
on and i'll tell you for why
because this site is within the draft
joint local plan settlement boundary
it's in that submission so the
likelihood of there being development
here
even this application lapses is
insignificantly high
so uh i'm really disappointed we're not
we're not here with all the information
i personally think that on balance and
it's a very close balance
that i i wouldn't be prepared to support
the scale and mass of the potential
development here i don't think this is
uh appropriate in its setting and uh and
and i would support any move uh moving
or seconding to
refuse this but it is very much on
balance chair
thank you um councillor field
yes i think i'm moving to the point
where i too
would not support the application
certainly concerned about the um
development in the gap between the two
elements of hobson
particularly since that gap is
accommodates an ancient monument
and has been said the size and mass of
these matting of these buildings seems
quite
uh excessive
and really uh they're of a style which
couldn't be regarded as respecting the
local vernacular it's not uh clearly not
suffolk style it's somewhat universal to
the country perhaps
um and i too regret as i've said before
the lack of the early archaeological
work that might have
established whether this is in or is not
a
a a an ancient site um
the place of execution of a king um
and i think other than that most of what
i feel has been said so i'll leave it
there
i shall listen to others and make a
final decision
thank you chancellor mayor
thank you chair to me this is this is
all about design
and it's it's about not just the design
of the buildings but how they tie in
with that
ancient monument it's
it will be so easy for the buildings to
detract from the monument hide the
monument and yet
if it's well designed they could also
enhance that monument
tie the whole thing together i do note
in the
um written submission by the parish
council
they make a suggestion that the design
be submitted to the suffolk design
review panel
i admit my ignorance i don't i've not
heard of them before um
but perhaps that's something um that
could be looked at in the
this is such a critical design that
should that design rest on the shoulders
of a heritage officer and our planning
officer
is it not a wider discussion that should
take place because this is
potentially or is a um a site of
national importance
looking at the building as they are
suggested to me at the moment
i think a well-placed dustbin could hide
the monument from the um
from the road so is that pathway wide
enough
the buildings do seem quite large
monumental almost
um and that would detract from the
ancient monument
so i think we have got a design issue
here and
i don't know if anybody can throw any
light on the suffolk design review panel
or whether that's even an option that's
open to us
thank you may i come in on that point
german
um so the suffolk design review panel uh
they don't tend to look at schemes of
this size if i'm perfectly honest with
you they tend to be far larger sizes
that they they look at but they are
a a group of architects that um if the
applicant
wanted to could pay for them to look at
this
scheme um that there's no
there's no formal requirement for us or
procedure for us to um
set this aside to be put forward to that
group they are
a volunteer voluntary group of
architects who come together to make
comments on design
um we wouldn't be able to refuse to on
that issue either that would be a very
um
concerning thing to do so i would
urge that that is not something that we
should be considering in this context
and
the application needs to be determined
on its own merits
okay um thank you um councillor madison
thank you yes i i found the
the read beforehand of of the papers
particularly difficult
um village that i'm not not familiar
with to any
degree really and um
this this i couldn't i think the the the
pictures
and and the slides would have been quite
handy
a few days ago in this particular case
uh and
in other times um we could argue well
for it for a site visit actually
to understand it better um and
it was obviously even more uncomfortable
um realizing that probably the outline
shouldn't have been granted in the first
place
but here we are um
having said that um
and understood the problem rather more
um the landscape impact
is is actually quite significant the
difficulty is
can we can we get up to four dwellings
in this
plot which will not have a big impact on
the landscape and
that's quite difficult um
if they were smaller they would have a
little bit less impacts
um so i kind of sympathize with the
the feeling that this is this is not the
right design
i i really don't without going and
looking at it all i don't really
understand whether
you know what would be a better design
layout really that so
it's all quite difficult
it's uncomfortable unsatisfactory
situation that we're in
thank you i'm just going to throw my
toughness in with i know um counselor
milo wants to speak
but i want to say that i did go and have
a look at the the plot yesterday
and um and what i felt was well although
um the look and the appearance of the
the bungalow on plot one is is a you
know is a fair design
i think the actual placement of it there
cuts out most of the views
that you get from the road as you come
over the bridge and you look
to see the monument like i say that the
plot one would absolutely obscure most
of that until he got past that house
and there might be one quick view as she
drive past but that would like to say
blot out
that the slide jamie just had on that
that first one there like i could say
that
is what i would say as you come to the
footpath on the
as the footpath meets the road that is
the main i would say the main view of
the monument and that will be completely
cut out by having that bug below there
so i'm that's my tuppence worth and um
councillor miller would you like to say
your piece yes uh thank you chair i must
admit i do agree with and concur with
all the comments been made
i do agree that um paragraph 127 of the
mppf particularly a
and c apply and also paragraph 130 i
don't think
these buildings fit in with the nature
of a suffolk village i could envision
them on a housing estate
in a town um and the village
perhaps would like the two the two
bedroom houses which are more
appropriate
um so at this stage i i don't feel i can
support this application thank you
is there anyone else who would like to
speak
because i don't have any um proposal for
one thing or another
so um so yeah i don't want to be
flailing around in the dark but um
councilman mansell
uh thank you chair um i think i think
we've heard
from from everyone on the committee now
and and there certainly seems to be
a a lack of support for this application
so um i'll i'll be bold enough to
make a proposal that we um go for
refusal
um on the grounds that the design is not
appropriate to the location
um and nor does it enhance the uh
surroundings of the listed monument
there are also some landscape impacts
i'm sorry if i haven't got the relevant
numbers of the paragraphs of the
mppf but i think a lot of them have
already been mentioned
um you know somebody was saying that you
know can we actually get four
dwellings on here but they don't have to
be this big we've already established
that these are large
three-bedroomed houses so i'm sure there
are other
ways that you could fit four smaller
dwellings
which would have much less impact on the
landscape
and on the setting of the listed
monument
so i will propose that we go for a
refusal
on on on landscape uh layer
layout and bulk you know the bulk and
the size of the design rather than the
actual
you know anything else i think and the
setting of the
of the list you know the views of the uh
listed monument
i i hope that that is sufficient
what um john has come back with is the
proposed dwellings if
approved but by reason of their poor
layout dominate
scale and appearance failed to be in
character and are not sympathetic with
the local area in history
and is not and does not sufficiently
demonstrate local distinctiveness
and fails to add to the design quality
and function of the area
contrary to gp1 hb1 h13
cs5 and mppfp127
and 130. and i also see that um
counselor muller would like to speak uh
yes thank you chair yes i would concur
with what um
counselor manslaughter said and i am
happy to second her proposal for reviews
of this application thank you
okay thank you very much um so um
so i'm john would you like to come in
and correct um out my my
mangled um speech yes
sorry uh i forgive my the grammar there
um i was just trying to put uh
counsellor's thoughts together quite
quickly of what we've just been uh
listening to
so uh just to put it in context i think
you know what members are trying to say
here that the proposed dwellings
in terms of obviously what we've got
before us which is the
layout scale and appearance and
landscaping um
ultimately um we
can i just play with me one moment i've
just realized something
uh two seconds
okay um
i'm just debating the word layout um
in terms of layout is it more
towards the sort of scale and dominance
of the
buildings than the actual sighting or
it's actually not layout but it's more
of the sighting of the building so we
need to change
is it the layout of the sighting i'm not
where i think plot one i think that part
should be left clear
so we're we're not into the layout
specifically about the entire
development we're into the sighting of
the pacific plots here so
my suggestion would be this then the
proposed uh
the proposed where the post dwellings if
approved would by reason of poor citing
dominant scale and appearance fail to be
in character and not sympathetic
with the local area in history does not
sufficiently demonstrate local
distinctiveness
and fails to add to the design quality
and function of the area
and you may notice that that picks up on
certain key aspects what the nppf
actually says
so in total that would be contrary to
your local plan policies of
gp one hb one which refers to historic
uh settings um h13 which is
design of housing as well as then cs5
which talks about general environment
and good design within that environment
uh within the countryside especially and
then we have the npp
f uh paragraph one two seven and
one thirty specifically as well
counselor manslaughter and counselor
mueller are you happy with that
uh yeah yes and i was going to to try
and comment on the
the the sort of layout and design
because obviously
the layout of the this design of house
is causing a problem
that's not to say that the this sort of
layout
for smaller dwellings may may work so
i think i can't really separate the
layout
with the mass and scaling of it because
i think they are too intertwined i think
you know you can't have you can't have
this layout with smaller houses it might
it might be all right we don't know what
those
houses are going to look like so they
are sort of linked but yes i'm happy
with
with that list that uh john pate mcgee
has suggested
well i'd love to have you with that
chair thank you thanks
okay
sorry john did you want to come back um
just uh ultimately the only other thing
we could do is that rather than say poor
sighting we
could just say poor design dominant
scale and appearance
if we wanted to be a little bit broader
than specifically on the sighting
i mean i'm not proposing it but i think
the sighting is very important as well
i also see john matson still got his
hand up do you want to say something
else john
yeah i i did actually um counselor
mansell
in her proposal did did mention
landscaping
and um or the you know the impact on the
landscape i think
and um that is in what um the officers
are proposing as the reasons at the
moment i don't think
no i hadn't picked up on landscaping in
terms of what is the landscaping
causing harm to
you know the the the the size that
you know what what's being proposed is
has a considerable
impact on the on the landscape um
because
because it sits between the two
conservation areas
etc um as distinct from all the
arguments about the
the monument itself that's the point i
was anyways
it's it's up to the proposer and second
of really what they want in there
um if i can if i can come in there i
mean
i think i think john matherson is right
i mean there is a sort of landscape
issue because you're
uh i mean not that i'm familiar with
hoxson but it appears that you
you you go down that road and and there
will be a significant change
to the to the set to the to the views as
you go from one bit of hoxton to the
next
uh regardless of whether there is a
monument in that field
uh there is going to be significant
change in the landscape and
and that gap between the two bits of
hoxton appears to be
uh significant to the community so it is
going to affect the landscape of that
gap between the two bits of
of hoxson so whether that is truly
landscape or whether it's just
fitting in with its surroundings i'm not
quite sure of the difference
i think the danger if i may um
is that the principle of development of
up to four
in some form has been agreed
so the the gap or the
uh cr the development creep uh
that may be sort of joining the village
up together is already sort of set out
in part in that principle landscaping of
us
of a scheme you know we're down to the
sort of boundary treatments and
and other aspects of that more so i
would perhaps
suggest but you know if we're saying the
land
when you tie lance there was design
encompasses
all of the issues of landscaping and
character and part of the rural
character that we're trying to
ensure that we've got a good quality
development within so
you know in broad terms you know we can
we can pull uh poor sighting i would
perhaps then
suggest that we do take out the word
sighting what we're dealing with is the
design as a whole
so poor design dominant scanner and
appearance
and i can say and landscaping fails to
be in character and not sympathetic with
the local area
okay that that that sounds fine to me
are you happy with that counselor as
well yes i'm also happy with that thank
you chair
okay so john would you like to read out
what you've got then thank you
uh one moment let me just read it from
my head one more time
oh i'm john madison have you still got
your hand up is there something else
you'd like to say
no cool thanks
okay yep so i'll read that through one
more time then the proposed dwellings if
approved
would by reason of poor design dominant
scan and appearance and landscaping
fail to be in character and are not
sympathetic with the local area and
history
does not does not sufficiently
demonstrate local distinctiveness
and fails to add to the design quality
and function of the area
and therefore the contrary to policies
gp1 hb1
h13 of the local plan and cs5 of the
core strategy
and as well as nppf paragraphs
one two one two seven and one thirty
okay cool
so um so i'll now move to the vote and
um i will ask the um
the governance officer to conduct the
roll call vote
robert
because my order of proceedings has
decided not to work so i will go through
members but it won't be in alphabetical
order most likely
so i will start with
counselor andrew stringer
four counselor dave muller
counselor john field four
councillor john matheson for refusal
council lavinia hattingham
council richard mayer four
and councillor sarah mansell four
thank you chair i make that as unanimous
mr duprey
um yes i agree unanimous
thank you um so then we move on to um
item number eight
site inspection
which um sorry we don't have any
site inspections to report okay cool so
then i formally closed the meeting at um
1 18 and um thanks very much sorry
do you mind if i make a comment sure
on our earlier item in thurston sorry
i'll put the video on
in our earlier item in in
thurston uh it did say that in the
conclusion uh that the most
relevant documents were the
neighborhood plan documents in future
could they be in the bundle
if they are the primary document in the
offices assessment could we at least
have those relevant policies
in the document because we can't then
get a judgment
uh yeah and it actually protracted this
morning because what we had to do was
tease out all of that and that had been
really helpful it would have been on one
page
just all of those relevant neighborhood
plan documents if they are the primary
source
of the conclusion which they were on
that item thank you jeff
thanks yeah well john you can take that
back can't you
i can but equally i'm not sure how to
square that with
all of the local plan core strategy and
other primary documents there's a lot of
primary
policies um in that context um
that the the other problem with the
neighborhood plan is that it's about 87
pages
long um and you also have to understand
the you know background text that goes
with all of those policies
um and i i think specifically just
i highlighted policies today because i
needed to but in order to
be fair to the entire neighbourhood plan
it does need to be read in its entire
context
um so i can take that back to philip
isabel but i
don't know where we can go with that and
i will have to seek his guidance
i've got suddenly got loads of hands
going up so i'm not really sure what's
going on anyway sarah manson would you
like to say something
uh yeah well i was i've just looked
flicked back through my
um documents and on pages 17
and 18 of our paper bundle we do
have a summary of policies
within our own um plan and then there is
a title which says neighborhood plan
status and it just says we're a
neighborhood plan or something
could we not have a list of policies
in a similar manner to the ones we have
in our own local plan because they all
form part of our
uh development plan
it's fair enough yep um john madison do
you wanna yeah
yeah with with sarah on on that i think
the
um that maybe what what john needs to
take back to phillip
is the um that officers need to get
used to the having a having a
neighborhood plan as a primary issue
and and discussing it as much as they
discussed
the the the balancing of the mppf
in order to tilt the balance if you see
what i mean
and so i i think
it's unreasonable to have the whole set
yes 17.
you